jonathan whitney staff reporter with the
wall street journal the reverend jesse
jackson has been in cuba the last couple
of days seeking the release of political
prisoners is that an appropriate role
for a democratic presidential candidate
to play
i don't know why not if he can if he can
achieve the release of some people from
cuban prisons
i guess that's all of good
this is the front page of the baltimore
sun this morning and as you see in the
very middle of the paper article by fred
barnes sun staff correspondent dateline
is havana says the reverend jesse
jackson fervently campaigned for
normalized relations between the united
states and cuba yesterday urging
president reagan to visit cuba and
invite fidel castro to america is it
very very realistic to expect that we
can normalize relations with cuba mr
whitney well i think we could have
normal relations with cuba a lot faster
than most people think probably
maybe even within five years if we began
to adopt a rational attitude toward cuba
good morning and welcome to our call-in
show this morning our guest is a very
special one mr jonathan quitney who's a
staff reporter with the wall street
journal has been with the journal for 13
years mr whitney has covered a variety
of beats for the wall street journal and
became involved in foreign reporting
when the russians invaded afghanistan
he's also done investigative reporting
including articles that first explore
exposed richard allen's conflict of
interest in the reagan administration
and revealing faa administrator jalen
helms as a specialist in bankrupting
companies for profit forcing his
resignation he was in the peace corps
and has taught in nigeria and has done a
lot of backpacking in africa and asia
his education consists of a bachelor's
degree in journalism from the university
of missouri and a master's degree in
history from new york university he's
originally from india indianapolis
indiana and he's with us for the next
hour to discuss the headlines on the
morning newspapers we'd like to invite
you to get out your morning newspaper
give us a call tell us what's on the
front page of your newspaper we'll be
talking about foreign policy phone lines
are open for viewers in all areas of the
country those numbers appear there at
the bottom of your screen and if you
have a question or a comment or if you'd
like to tell us what's on your morning
newspaper please feel free to give us a
call i need to say something at this
point which is you've mentioned
repeatedly the wall street journal that
has nothing to do with my appearance
here today and they have not approved or
disapproved anything i may say i'm here
because i wrote a book endless enemies
for congdon and weed publishers and i'm
here in that regard only that was my
next introduction okay everyone we do
have a journalist though which is why i
explained that you write for the wall
street journal this is mr whitney's book
endless enemies as you can see here i'm
going to turn to the very inside of this
book and quote from it to give you an
idea of what it had to say it's chapter
14 and it's entitled making our bed in
central america part two and i quote for
the past quarter century the united
states has fretted and fumed and applied
great resources trying to change
conditions in latin america yet the
condition the u.s has concentrated on
changing has not been bloodshed poverty
illiteracy or disease the u.s effort has
been directed toward changing the
government of cuba where all these
exiles exist less than almost anyone's
evils excuse me it exists less than
almost anywhere else in latin america
and the u.s has punished any nation that
tried even slightly to emulate cuba why
is that so mr quinn
well
why is which though
basically we have for 40 years conducted
a foreign policy designed at fighting
what we see is a communist menace in the
third world and
in traveling to more than 80 countries
and spending years of of talking to
people abroad and visiting the scenes of
these crises which are kind of set out
chapter by chapter in endless enemies i
don't see that that threat at all i
think we have misperceived everything
that's happened in africa asia latin
america where we have intervened and
whether whether the people in charge of
our intervention have have misperceived
it or whether they have have cynically
been acting in in their own interests
and there are a lot of reasons for
saying that uh
financial connections uh among leaders
of the american government to
interests that have been protected in in
these countries but whatever the reason
is the policy is clearly backfired and
we've done a great deal of harm to our
own well-being rather than advance our
own cause in the press release that came
out with your book explaining it and
explaining that you would also be in
town it says and i quote the book shows
how foreign policy based on fear has led
us to become the principal patron of the
institution of dictatorship now usually
when you read reports in the uh in the
papers about our foreign policy it says
we are trying to establish democracy in
foreign countries not dictatorship uh
and even more it says we're
trying to promote the cause of free
enterprise and capitalism and yet we do
neither in the the places where we have
intervened and established governments
uh in in the philippines and zaire and
indonesia and iran under the shah and in
guatemala and
we can go on and on uh we not only have
set have often destroyed working
democracies uh freely elected
governments but we have also destroyed
uh free market competition and protected
monopoly interests in all the countries
i've just named and others zaire the old
congo and many others we have overseen
the establishment of a socialist system
that has nationalized all economic
activity
has created national boards and selling
organizations so that every farmer every
miner can only deal with the national
government
in in selling his his product uh people
are not free to start their own
businesses to carry out economic
activities as we have here
and to me this is terribly sad because i
really think the united states has
created
the the best way of of running a society
both politically and economically and i
think we have enormous gifts to give to
the world but we're really denying the
world those gifts with our military
power let's take a look at the front
page of a few the newspapers we have out
here on the east coast this is the front
page of usa today and this main headline
or it has a big picture here a drawing
of the space shuttle and says search on
today for shuttle flaw story over here
says nasa inspectors meet today at
discovery's oceanside launch pad to
search for damage that has postponed the
maiden flight of the hard luck shuttle
and to think about when it can go up
again over here on the right side it
says senate okay's 21 year old drinking
age dateline washington the senate voted
tuesday to withhold highway construction
funds from states that refused to enact
a minimum drinking age of 21. then down
here continues with the story of the
discovery countdown to a letdown it says
and a small story over here that says a
record 25 million women hold full-time
jobs but the story that we're kind of
talking about today is up here at the
very top and it says jackson castro deal
to free 22 americans and dateline havana
cuban president fidel castro and the
reverend jesse jackson said about 1am
eastern daylight time today that 22
american prisoners will be released from
cuban jails and will return thursday to
washington dc with jackson
so what so 22 prisoners are released
does this really change anything
jonathan whitney well for those 22
people and i don't know who they are and
what they've done
one assumes that uh
these are political crimes we're talking
about and that uh he's not freeing uh
murderers and hijackers and arsonists uh
i'm unfamiliar with the the facts of
those cases but for those 22 people
certainly changes things for them uh
i i doubt that it's going to change
american policy as long as we have
administrations that have created the
policy we have with cuba this is the
op-ed page of the new york times today
james reston concentrates his column
today on jesse jackson's trip to cuba
and the first paragraph says
presidential candidates have for many
years campaign from foreign capitals
usually it's good television and
therefore good politics but jesse
jackson's trip to cuba and central
america is something different it's bad
politics bad diplomacy and bad manners
what do you think of that jonathan
quitney well i mean he's entitled to his
opinion i don't know why why does he say
that
he thinks it's inappropriate for jesse
jackson to be in cuba
well i mean if jackson or anybody can go
down there and free 22 innocent people
and as i say i don't know that these
people are innocent i don't know who
they are or what their cases are but
assuming that they don't deserve to be
in jail uh if he can go down there and
free them why isn't that all to the good
if if it uh if it even begins a first
step in a healing process of relations
between two countries that should have a
close relationship and a friendly
relationship why is that a bad thing
phone lines are open for viewers in all
areas of the country if you have a
question or comment for jonathan whitney
we'd like to invite you to get out your
morning newspaper and give us a call and
we'll be taking those calls uh just as
soon as we can let's hold up the front
page of the new york times today
and over here kind of in the middle of
the page aid phase out is seen for foes
of sand and east as it says
senate no vote comes as money runs out
the lead paragraph says the senate
decision on monday against providing
additional aid to nicaraguan rebels this
year will force at least a temporary
phase out of american support for the
insurgents senior administration
officials said today what do you think
of that
well you keep saying what i think of
something that happened yesterday one of
the things i think is that that these
things have to be put in the context of
what's been happening for 30 or 40 years
and they rarely are
we forget what's happened in the past we
think that lebanon is a crisis that's
happened in the past two years
few people are aware that there was a
working democracy and
a peaceful democracy in lebanon and had
been going on that way for five years
when in 1957 a cia operation
upset that carefully balanced system uh
rigging the government in favor of of
the christians because we decided we
wouldn't be satisfied with a peaceful
neutral free trading lebanon that we
wanted a military ally well what that
did was touch off a reaction a
civil war by the muslim majority in the
country which
required marine intervention well at
least we saw it as requiring marine
intervention in 1958 and again in the
past couple years we wind up leaving
hundreds of dead marines behind uh
without accomplishing anything except
turning a peaceful uh country and a
democratically elected country into a a
bloodbath in in latin america
in 1954 we had a government in guatemala
that was
a democratically chosen government the
last such government that country has
ever had run by
what i guess we'd call moderate
certainly people who supported a
multi-party democracy and free
enterprise the the the
their hero was franklin roosevelt they
began to adopt labor reform legislation
that was worded right after the wagner
act we started
a campaign to overthrow that government
we raised a c.i.a army
in honduras exactly as the cia army
we've gone in honduras now to work
against the nicaraguans
guatemalan government screened
this was done at the behest of united
brands corporation
which
went to the administration at the time
through general walter bedell smith who
had been head of the cia and was then
number two at the state department uh
smith told united brands he wanted the
presidency of that corporation on his
retirement from public service in
exchange for this thinking he had his
future business career locked up he goes
to the dulles brothers who had also been
uh collected legal fees from work done
in the sale of united brands guatemalan
properties and arranges the overthrow of
that government now in destroying that
government
uh eisenhower blatantly lied to the
american public and that sounds like
strong language but there are quotes in
endless enemies that give a chronology
uh details and and facts that i think
leave that indisputable lied to the
country about the notion that the reds
are in control there and that they were
the soviets were using guatemala as a
base to spread revolution throughout
central america and specifically
mentioned el salvador this was just
totally untrue
guatemala at the time that
democratically chosen government had
bought a small shipment of arms to try
to defend itself against the cia army
that was
arrayed on its borders when we overthrew
that government what we did was
overthrow and destroy a model of a
democratic system for central america to
follow a fidel castro watched that very
carefully
and saw what would happen if you you you
deviate in slight ways from
an american imperialism down there and
decided that a marxist police state was
the only way to go and in his training
schools right now on the isle of pines
in cuba where a lot of terrible ideas
are being handed out to
the leaders from all over the third
world emerging nations castro
specifically teaches the the guatemalan
experiment in democracy from 1947 to 54
that we ended and the chilean experiment
in which salvador allende also tried to
continue multi-party democracy and
basically free private ownership while
reforming the ownership but while
changing breaking up monopoly control
over uh basic resources and castro
teaches that
this proves that you cannot succeed in
breaking up american-owned monopolies
unless you become a marxist police state
i i think that's a tragic situation our
guest this hour is jonathan quinn he's a
staff reporter with the wall street
journal he's also the author of this
book which we're going to be talking
about endless enemies and it says the
making of an unfriendly world phone
lines are open today to talk about the
headlines on the morning newspapers but
also joining us in our studios today
some special guests representatives of
the republican communications
association who consist basically of
press secretaries for different
republican representatives here on
capitol hill we welcome them they'll be
asking a few questions in just a few
moments right now let's go to the phone
let's see new york city new york good
morning you're on the air go ahead
please
good morning first of all
i want to
congratulate you and
she's been for a great show that you
present to a lot of viewers here in
america thank you i am from central
america i'm from costa rica
and uh i would like to
make a comment and probably disagree a
little bit would you guess
he not necessarily
a authoritarian government have to
become a
totalitarian government as he mentioned
in in guatemala like
from one government the united states
was
supporting one government and place
another government uh maybe worse as you
know in his view but if we look at the
country
or the government in venezuela first of
all
it was a
totalitarian government it became a
democracy
i'm concerned about the change of a
status quo in central america
my country especially
ever since nicaragua or the sandinistas
took power in 1979
there has been a terrorist
in the
in the capital san jose
and uh also there have been clashes in
the border with costa rica
sometimes uh i hear many of these
reporters that costa rica has a base
for anti sandinistas
they i would like to find out if is any
proof
for
these journalists
that say that costa rica has a
is supporting the pastoral
guerrillas there is no evidence
whatsoever
and president monge have
said very clearly
we do not support we are not using our
territory our sovereign territory by
supporting any
uh anti-government uh you know the santi
the sandinista government and this
underneath the government so uh i don't
agree
with uh
your guess and when he said that
uh
the
government
of guatemala became even worse
sometimes we cannot put the facts
together all right new york city let's
give mr clinton a chance to respond
thanks for the call well if
usually i like to stick to things that
i've seen and heard and i've not been to
costa rica and i've not been to
nicaragua although i'd love to go to
both places but if he suggests that
costa rica is not now the base for uh
guerrillas acting against nicaragua uh i
i i
i i can't see how he can deal with the
massive evidence to the contrary that's
in the papers we read every day
eden pastora was there on
the bomb explosion that went off just a
few weeks ago
killing a number of people i think is is
proof of the guerrilla presence in costa
rica
and i don't know how anybody can can
doubt that as for the the difference in
governments between what was in
guatemala and what is there now
again the evidence is simply
overwhelming the tales of murder and
torture and terror that are relayed in
in endless enemies
chapter and verse
contrasted with what had been
a peaceful democratic country
i can't imagine that he would that the
average citizen of guatemala is is
happier under the the conditions that
exist today than
under the conditions that would exist in
a peaceful free-market democratically
chosen government inside of the new york
times today the very middle of the page
a picture of roberto davison says as he
arrived monday at the airport miami and
the headline over here says secrecy
shrouds dabasan visit hosts site
personal safety and politics is reason
an article by hedrick smith dateline
washington the movements of roberto
davison the salvadoran writers who is
visiting the united states are being
kept secret as a matter of prudent
politics and personal safety his jose
there is some
threats that his life is threatened
while he's here in the united states how
realistic is that it's it's really
remarkable to me if the stories are true
and i have no reason to doubt them that
he was behind the plot to assassinate
assassinate our ambassador that he still
maintains the support he does and and
the the salvadoran power structure
maintains the support it does
in washington i have been del salvador
and i've seen
the the evidence there of of
the incredible reign of terror being
carried out by that government um
i've also walked through cuba and gone
where i wanted to go spent close to a
month talking to who i wanted to talk to
with my own interpreter uh and and free
of of government surveillance and i
really can't imagine that the average
american if he could repeat those
experiences and see what life is like
for the average cuban and see what life
is like for the average salvadoran that
the average american wouldn't
favor to live in cuba forced to make
that choice even as much of a
dictatorship as it is uh it
still is a it tends to look out for its
people
the average person
everyone was was well dressed well cared
for there was peace there was a
at least a basic freedom to be able to
choose one's occupation the place of
one's residence who one marries
we support many countries around the
world that lack all of these freedoms we
have installed governments around the
world that deprive people of these
freedoms
the conditions in el salvador are
ones where the average person is fearful
of his life to say anything at all out
of line there is less free speech there
than there is in cuba
there is is less free economic movement
there than there is in cuba there is
certainly
greater fear there than there is in cuba
where the average person can't go to bed
at night and be sure that he or his
neighbor isn't going to wind up in
little pieces in a ditch the next
morning we're going to take a phone call
and then after this we'll be taking a
question from one of the our the guests
in our audience but first let's go
across the potomac river to arlington
virginia you're on the air go ahead
please good morning
i am calling because this is the first
time i think that i have ever heard
someone
a news person or someone get up on the
air and say
the things that i have known for a long
time from my reading and in on
investigation to be true about south
america
and central america
i read
some years ago
i believe a book by philip agee
the cult of intelligence
and uh it was very very interesting
he didn't write that book i
know i'm sorry go ahead what's your
question
i don't really have a question i have
just i just wanted to make a comment
that it's wonderful to hear somebody
that speaks out the truth we've been
listening to lies the lies in the front
page of the paper
about central america from the white
house
and all
that
and the american people really don't
have a
a basis for judging what is really going
on because i don't think a good many of
them are aware okay arlington let me ask
you a question do you think what mr
whitney says is correct that we are
supporting dictatorships more often than
democracies and places like central we
certainly are we always have arlington
thanks for the call any response
responsibility
well that was really more an opinion
than a question i think she may have
been a little confused the cia in the
cult of intelligence was written by john
marks and victor marchetti
philip agee wrote a book called
inside the company cia diary let's take
a question from our audience the
republican communications association uh
go ahead please
uh mr quitney are you familiar with
witness by whitaker chambers
on
the book only reading about it i've
never read the book i didn't read it i
was my question was in reference to the
question of the
excerpt from your book that carl quoted
and in that he gave the difference
between communism and our way of life
and that was the reason i asked if you
were familiar with his book well i'm
familiar with with communist countries
and our way of life and i've traveled
pretty widely and in endless enemies in
the uh
last chapter i do a number of
comparisons of of pairs of countries
that seem to me similar in starting out
except for the paths they chose
one
a more free enterprising path and one a
more socialistic path
morocco and algeria indonesia and
malaysia burma and thailand
a half a dozen pairs of countries and in
every case i think the evidence shows
that
the more free enterprise one allows the
more productive a society is going to be
and the more freedom in
politically that one allows the more
productive a society is going to be
free enterprise countries free market
countries do a much better job of
providing goods and services for their
people in those countries on the
socialist model
to me it seems the only reason
any country has today of choosing a
socialist model is that that is the only
means available of avoiding american
domination and imperialism by american
corporate monopolies and uh
that to me is is an immense tragedy it's
often a valid reason uh it's often the
only way this can happen and in going
down in the in the same chapter uh in
endless enemies i go down the list of
countries that we often associate as
being in the soviet camp
and
except for libya which is basically run
by a nut uh
every one of the countries we associate
as as being uh
in the red camp as as the american
government might put it whether we're
talking about angola and mozambique or
syria or nicaragua or cuba or wherever
basically every one of those countries
got that way
by trying to
avoid
a military threat from the united states
or a perceived american presence in
south africa and israel
and
that to me is an enormous tragedy and i
think a lot of those countries would
love to break away from that system now
i think uh what we've seen in the past
few years and heard from the presidents
of angola and mozambique show pretty
clearly that they would
they see the the socialist uh
limitations on what they're doing and
would like to
begin to join
western trading partners and to begin
dealing more in a free market but that
they can't do that as long as they're
under military attack from weapons we've
helped supply
energies we've helped release uh and
through south africa and in the case of
angola directly with american military
intervention which by the way preceded
soviet military intervention and the
chronology is very carefully set out in
endless enemies
this is the washington times for today
john lofton's journal it's a column
which appears regularly in the times
says jonathan quitney tips his hand and
in the second paragraph it says and i
quote i thought of this absurd analysis
last week when i heard wall street
journal reporter jonathan whitney at the
cato institute discussing his new book
endless enemies the making of an
unfriendly world the thesis of which as
he described it seems to be that the
united states of america is the focus of
evil in the world as he sees it not a
sparrow drops anywhere on the globe that
it is not the fault of a sinister
american plot is that a correct
characterization of yours oh it's
absolutely not this guy came up to me at
the end of uh of a
speech i gave at the end of a long day
and thrust a tape recorder into my face
wearing sunglasses in doors and and i
really had no idea of that anything
would end up in in such a detailed print
and i gave a couple of flip answers to a
couple of questions that seemed to me
rather off the wall i asked him if he
had read the book he's never he hadn't
seen the book or read it
knew nothing of what was in it and
uh and obviously that's a
mischaracterization
anyone who's looking in here for a
defense of of the soviet union or of
communism is not going to find it um
i think that's
one of the most evil governments that
the world has yet come up with
and
the problem being that
we who have the potential to counter
that with much better ideas and a much
better way of governing instead have
tried to emulate that everywhere we go
in the world by imposing uh by bringing
our own military power to impose
military dictatorships and socialist
structures quite like what the soviet
union tries to do uh the difference
mainly in in the world is that we have
been very successful and the soviet
union has been
has has suffered failure after failure
throughout the third world
you're a newspaper reporter john lofton
is a newspaper reporter is that a common
technique going up to someone with
glasses indoors sticking a microphone in
their face and asking them some
questions not by me
let's go back to the phones fort worth
florida you're on the air go ahead
please how you doing mike where florida
go ahead you're on the air yeah i'm down
here almost to miami we're in lake north
florida and you know if your guest there
thinks that that cuba is so great there
that everything why we got these
millions of cubans fled cuba
and the peoples coming here said they
had you know wealth there and now they
castro took everything they owned from
them maybe uh
you know
anything nowadays with the democrat
party's got anything to do with apple
pie and hot dogs and god they're against
it anymore and i think you're guessing a
little bit to the left and maybe he got
to go live in cuba if he thinks that's
their way of life
well i didn't say that cuba was a good
way of life i said that it if you were
to rank all countries uh by the
desirability of the way of life they
provide for the average citizen cuba
would probably wind up in the upper half
certainly in the upper two-thirds it
isn't a free country most countries
aren't free countries uh it's a
socialist system uh
i don't happen to think socialism
provides very well i think it's a
foolish way of organizing an economy uh
he said i was from the left to me i
associate the left with socialism and i
associate the left with uh government
intervention and in the way uh people
lead their lives and um
that's certainly not what i advocate or
admire uh i think we do have to deal in
the same world that that cuba is we have
to deal with with all countries and i
think you have to to judge them uh for
what they are and to rail against cuba
as we have done to attack that country
uh to have provided the the very threat
that i think melds society behind castro
there i think without us
he would not have nearly the support he
does from his own people and it is a
thorough and solid support uh
and and i think
he might not have survived in office
after the economic problems of the 1960s
and if he had survived
he probably would have had to to take a
different attack away from socialism and
more toward
an american orientation a marketplace
american marketplace orientation there
aren't millions of cubans who have fled
that country there are about a million
about ten percent of the population and
those were the ten percent that did
suffer uh when castro came in because
they had the wealth and um he did take
it away from them but the majority of
the people wound up better off better
off than
the vast majority of the people i see in
the central american countries we
support the kids are clothed everybody
in cuba is well fed they aren't free um
there are people literally on every
street corner committees representatives
of the local committees for defense of
the revolution that watch where everyone
goes uh watch who comes to your house
where you go what you bring home from
the store who your friends are
i wouldn't want to live under that kind
of society and most americans wouldn't
but most americans wouldn't want to live
under the kind of society most countries
have
the question is whether we uh try to
create enemies out of countries or
whether we try to look at what our own
interests are which is to have
good trading friendly relationships with
as many countries as possible and i
think cuba could become one of those
countries would be one of those
countries now if we hadn't adopted the
attack we did in 1960. our guest this
morning is jonathan whitney the author
of this book endless enemies the making
of an unfriendly world we're talking
about the headlines on the morning
newspapers next call us from houston
texas good morning do you have your
morning newspaper
uh yes
the reason i wanted to talk is the
comparison between reagan going to china
and jesse jackson going to cuba
it seems that uh it's good politics and
good economics for reagan to go to china
and not and the man just stated that uh
the good interest of america would be to
have a trading party with cuba why not
run with china if you can do with china
you can do it with cuba and if you can
do it with south africa you can probably
do with angola right thank you
i'd love to comment on that because he
is making a wonderful point
a little more than a year ago i also had
the chance to spend a month walking
through china
i wasn't nearly as free there and
couldn't go quite as openly as i could
in cuba because of the far greater
restrictions the chinese government
places on its people and on foreigners
and on all forms of travel i was able to
escape government supervision for a
while we would get up at four o'clock in
the morning really to be ahead of the uh
to get up before the government
supervisors who were trying to shepherd
us around were and i took my own
mandarin translator from the united
states and
we would get bicycles
which we had rented secretly while going
out to dinner and
go out to farms into the countryside and
also get on buses alleging that we were
going to some tourist attraction but get
off
in the middle and then try to to go on
private transportation as far as we
could until eventually we would be
arrested and brought back
but what we saw and heard there i think
again if the average american were to
travel through china and see what life
is like for the average chinese and
travel through cuba and see what life is
like for the average cuban i can't
imagine there is an american who would
not
rather if forced to make that choice
be in cuba and be a friend of the cubans
and yet in china we
we find them all right to deal with
we send the president our president goes
over there and actually makes deals to
send them nuclear material and
technology with with defense
applications
and yet in cuba we persist in this war
effort i think what happened
there's another irony at work here
in in china we were roundly defeated in
in our major war effort against them
which did last 25 years and immediately
after we we suffered this defeat and
stopped being an enemy of theirs and
withdrew our armies from their borders
uh
we suddenly found we could have a
friendly relationship with that country
uh
to the extent that that they are good
trading partners which i think may be an
overrated extent uh because of the
repressive nature of their society uh
we're certainly better off for having
the relations we do uh than we were
being at war and leaving
uh 50 or 100 000 american lives over
there
aimed at fighting this chinese
government one of the things in john
lofton's uh critique of your book says
he asked you he says at least in his
article what is the united states done
that as bad as the u.s invasion of
afghanistan what's your answer to that
well to try to uh
i mean in the article i cited vietnam uh
i was giving short answers to to
questions that that he was posing not
not quite nearly as precisely as your
question just now i think it's hard to
to rank
that kind of evil a lot of people
died in vietnam a lot of people died in
afghanistan neither of those countries
was being offered a chance to determine
its own course
i've traveled widely through afghanistan
i love afghanistan i traveled through it
when it was
an independent country and i've traveled
through it now that it's been invaded by
and dominated by the soviet union and a
great tragedy has fallen on those people
and they're being wiped out and i wish
there was was some way to stop it but
uh i think
the analogy if you want to draw it is
that this has been counterproductive for
the soviet union their interventions
have have not worked out uh well for
their interests any more than our
interventions have worked out well for
our interests our intervention in
vietnam was a disaster right now they're
bogged down in afghanistan losing
countless lives we really can't know
what's going on in afghanistan to the
extent we knew what was going on in
vietnam that evil we know precisely what
what happened in vietnam what's going on
in afghanistan is hard to report on i'd
love to get back there if i could but
there really is no way i think to to get
inside that country and see what's going
on there's no question that it's a
disaster phone call waiting from
scottsdale arizona good morning and
you're on the air do you have your
morning newspaper uh no i don't good
morning good morning do you have a
question for our guest
i'm very happy to listen to your guest
he's a wonderful man
i'd like to thank you
about
israel
and see how
we support that government and ignoring
a hundred million
arab people in that area
we support in israel even israel it's a
terrorist
government they have
they have no democracy
they can blow any
house of those palestinian people
the palestinian and there they are
second-class citizens
and here we are we give them 15 million
dollar a day you know just for them to
buy a bomb and just
cluster bomb and all that you know
that's i think that's not fair
i think the american policy is very
wrong in the middle east
uh i'd like to see he's going on
what country are you from sir i'm from
lebanon all right thanks for the call
well uh
israel i've not really dealt with in
endless enemies i've never been there i
think it's a unique situation and
therefore not really uh instructive to
look at our relationship there in the
situations i've tried to deal with the
united states has been trying to further
its own interests and i think has failed
our actions have backfired and i think
our interests have been set back in the
unique case of israel i think the
american people
have made a conscious decision to
go beyond our interests and to look
after the best interests of israel i
think this is not uh
just a single religious group i find
this attitude among millions of of
americans of all religious persuasions
they've made a a moral choice a a choice
of their desires to
support the best interests of israel and
to that extent we we have furthered the
best interests of israel
because that situation is unique and so
many americans are emotionally involved
in that issue i don't think it makes an
analogy with with anything else
let's take a look at the front page of
the washington time this morning a color
picture over here on the right of says
presidential counselor edmund meese left
taxed fbi director william webster at
seminar on domestic terrorism the
headline underneath it is quote
repression is no answer to terrorism
panelists say and the article says
police crackdowns and restrictions of
civil liberties play right into the
hands of terrorists and are the worst
possible response a series of speakers
told the jonathan institute's conference
on terrorism yesterday
over here on the
left-hand side of the front page down a
little bit senate okay's bill tying
drinking age to funds lead paragraph
despite warnings from conservatives that
it would encroach on states rights the
senate yesterday voted 81 to 16 to
penalize states failing to raise the
legal drinking age to 21. up in the
upper right hand corner a picture of
senator gary hart and former vice
president walter mondale and it's an
article in the the lead or the
headline here says mondale heart shake
and become friends and that's on the
front page of most of the newspapers i
want to open this up though
and give you a look at the editorial
cartoon on the inside of the washington
times a day it's an editorial cartoon by
garner kind of speaks for itself
you can take a close look at a picture
of fritz mondale reaching over and
touching the finger of senator gary hart
and gary hart is saying fritz and i
worked out a unity deal that's garner in
the washington times this morning let's
go out to dallas texas good morning
you're on the air go ahead please yeah i
would tell my intelligent person your
journalist is there my husband is from
guatemala central america we were down
there in 1980 and i didn't go with the
tourists as i was a family member and
the president he's speaking there was a
cardboard arvind who was i was thrown by
our cia back in the 50s
and the guatemalan people still hold
that against us
and they
the
that was the regime down there right now
the people are
they go to sleep at night and they get
the next morning out there and wake up
tonight like you said earlier about
another country
and we kind of literally just last week
my husband's family
and uh
things are not better they're worse the
president lucas was a dictator
uh the so-called born again christian
was the dictator and the man there now
there's no difference it's just a
different name it's all the same policy
it's all the same
everything until the united states gets
asked until america is going to stay the
same okay
i'm very glad that this journalist
um
realizes this i've never heard it made
public before okay dallas let me ask you
a question or do you read the dallas
morning news no the dallas tom's herald
what do you think of that newspaper i
think it's fantastic the only reason i
ask you that is because we're going to
be in dallas covering the republican
national convention and we'll be
spending a day at both the times herald
and the dallas morning news so be sure
and tune in for that thanks for the call
mr clinton in response i'd like to
comment on that i'm glad she called if i
was a guatemalan i'd sure be
angry at the united states i mean we
overthrew
uh their government and imposed a brutal
series of dictatorships on them and
the american people have been lied to
about this as if this was somehow in the
american interest
i think the theme of endless enemies is
not that interventions like this
bring disaster to third world peoples
although they do it brings disaster to
to the united states um jacobo arbenz
was not a a communist if you go back and
read what he wrote and what he was
advocating and and it's through quotes
and through uh us government documents
even it's set out in great detail in
endless enemies what he was advocating
was the breakup of a fruit monopoly that
our own justice department
accused of overcharging americans for
fruit
he was was trying to bring a free market
that would have been the benefit of
american consumers
we overthrew that government in
protection of that market and
that really is another theme throughout
endless enemies it's the constant
battle between the justice department
and the state department over what's in
the best interests of the united states
the justice department tries to to break
up monopolies such as
over the fruit situation in central
america and over the oil situation in
iran where they brought suit against
exxon and mobile in the early 1950s to
try to break up a monopoly situation in
which only those companies under an
agreement with british petroleum were
allowed to
buy refine and market oil from iran
which was then the world's largest
supplier
what the government of iran the
democratically elected government of
iran wanted to do was break up this
monopoly and open it to the independent
refiners and retailers of the united
states which would have lowered
gasoline prices and heating oil prices
for the american consumer and the
justice department recognized this we go
in there as we did in 1953 we overthrew
that government we installed a dictator
the shah who brought terrible repression
to the iranians but that that that's not
the key thing what's in our interest is
that he also perpetuated this monopoly
costing the american consumer if if the
american public had had lost both the
wars we were fighting in guatemala and
in iran to overthrow those governments
and that we paid for if we had lost in
both those instances we would have come
out ahead because we would have had
lower prices for for oil and fruit
front page of the philadelphia inquirer
this morning a large picture of former
vice president walter mondale and
senator gary hart meeting together
yesterday in new york city that seems to
be on most of the pagers pages or front
pages out here on the east coast mondale
hartberry hatchet over here on the left
side jackson may accept prisoners has
high hopes of cuban release talking
about jackson's trip to cuba down here
underneath that it says mayor goode of
philadelphia to meet mondale to discuss
vice presidency he'll be flying to
minnesota to do that and then underneath
that a headline israel and lebanon a
heavy price
for both sides that's the headlines of
the philadelphia inquirer also a story
about the senate vote on the 21 drinking
age nationally across the country phone
lines are open for viewers in all areas
of the country if you have a question or
comment please feel free to give us a
call we're going to take another
question from our audience in just one
second but right now let's take a phone
call from san diego your next go ahead
please
yes i have a question for mr quinn go
ahead and i'd like to uh
ask him if he believes
according to the paper the other day the
san diego union
uh fidel castro said that he admired the
united states and that he would like to
uh
work with uh
candidate jackson to
work on
renewing relations with the united
states
and uh do you actually believe that he
admires the united states and uh
what we are for after you know bay of
pigs and assassination of tents on him
and boycotting and
everything that he that we've done
to cuba do you think there is a chance
at all that we can ever
[Applause]
uh
maintain relations with cuba and uh you
said five years do you think it could be
done before five years san diego thanks
for the call i think almost everybody in
the world who is familiar with american
goods and productivity as castro is and
this almost everyone in cuba is
admires it we do a much better job of
producing things than the soviets do um
while uh under castro the cuban people
have uh uh the average cuban has has uh
risen to the point where he has much
more economically than than he did
before there are stereos and washers and
dryers and in cuban homes i think they
know that they're inferior products and
they would much rather do trade with the
united states um the problem is that uh
we have
raised ourselves as an enemy of this
regime that would not tolerate it
which requires them to link up to the
soviet union for
military support the soviets really
didn't move in there militarily the
missiles didn't arrive until 1962 after
the bay of pigs which was an open
invasion and after numerous repeated
invasions that were done clandestinely
where boatloads of of uh
cia operatives were were dropped on that
island
to to kill castro to poison the sugar
crop to
sabotage the refineries and and the oil
system there to do everything to try to
to bring down that government um
castro has used that uh that enmity to
bring the soviets in where they're
giving four and a half billion dollars a
year in aid and this is what's largely
allowed castro to
elevate the the standard of living of
the average cuban this is the equivalent
of 2500 a year for every cuban family
that's an enormous subsidy compared to
the standards of living in the third
world and that's why they're able to do
so well despite an inefficient socialist
economy as i said earlier we have some
special guests in our studio today
representatives the republican
communications association which
consists of members of our press
secretaries republican members of the
house of representatives let's take
another question from our audience go
ahead please mr whitney uh do you feel
the us government needs the cooperation
of mr davasan the arena party and their
supporters in el salvador but more
importantly do you feel that
president-elect duarte
needs the cooperation and support of mr
davison if we're going to succeed in el
salvador and promote democracy
and secondly can you please comment on
whether you feel the u.s military
intervention
and actions in grenada constituted a
foreign policy success or failure for
the united states all right thanks for
the question
well
you're you're speaking i guess from a
different paradigm when you're talking
about succeeding in establishing
democracy in el salvador i don't see us
establishing democracy in el salvador
it's not the kind of place i would like
to live in
what i saw when i was down there last
year
i hope to god that the united states
doesn't need a man like roberto davos on
uh i don't imagine i can't understand
why we would need him uh why we need
to worry about which faction is going to
govern el salvador at all uh i think our
interests are in uh having peaceful
trade in that part of the world and by
uh promoting uh armed conflict uh as we
consistently have in that part of the
world i i don't see how it's furthering
our cause or the cause of democracy or
the cause of free enterprise once again
on the inside of the new york times
there's a picture of roberto davison who
is visiting capitol hill today and down
here in the lower right hand corner an
article by joel brinkley it says dabasan
is finding a friend on capitol hill
dateline washington aides to senator
jesse helm said today that he has been
defending roberto davison the salvadoran
rightist because the senator prefers mr
dabasan's politics to those of president
jose napoleon duarte of el salvador what
do you think of that
well
again presuming that that what we read
is true about dav we saw having plotted
against the american ambassador and we
we know that even if that's not true
uh papers directly uh uh
found with him uh uh directly linked him
to the assassination of the archbishop
down there and and his people and those
who support to the killings
uh i hate to even mention of a few
americans the point is of thousands and
thousands of of salvadorans uh who come
to see
this as the arm of the united states not
democracy and free markets but
repression and military control
socialist control where where uh
the economy and everything else is run
at gun point this is the face we're
presenting down there there are several
articles in the paper papers today that
many members of the house and the center
having trouble deciding whether or not
they should even meet with dobby son at
all for fear of hurting our relations
with mr duarte what do you think of that
senator jesse helms is going to be
holding a reception for mr davison here
on capitol hill wednesday evening well i
don't know if somebody wants to hold a
reception for somebody i i can't see
honoring a man with a past like that on
the other hand
just as with a number of
communist leaders uh
i think it's in the interest of the
united states to be able to deal with
whatever faction comes to power in these
countries and to make sure no faction uh
leader has been shot at with an american
gun so that they will have no reason to
be our enemy and will want to to trade
with us and deal with us the world is
full of dictatorships uh i sure wouldn't
like to be living in a country run by
roberto dobwisson i wouldn't like to be
living in a country that
i
would be run by what i suspect is is uh
the leftist faction that might take over
in his absence but
i it's hard for me to envision the
government of el salvador that
could possibly come to power in the next
few years that many americans would want
to be very friendly toward or or
live under uh
why not try to defuse that situation and
deal with it as peacefully as we can
pittsburgh pennsylvania thank you for
your patience and your next go ahead
please uh yes regarding central america
um there's a new school spot that says
that um the
um
el salvador and guerrillas are not
really communist motivated communist
ideology in fact they're motivated by um
poor land distribution and
the same sort of thought also says
nicaraguans really are not supplying
substantial amount of military aid this
is supported by
a statement by the former cia
analyst for central america in time
magazine he said that after 1981 there's
almost no evidence that garage would
have been sending any military material
any comment on this
well sure again
over over a period of 40 years of very
consistent policy among democratic and
republican administrations we've created
a situation where
basically the only alternative
revolutionaries in central america see
to a u.s imposed military imperialism is
this marxist system uh i don't think uh
that if it does take over in a country
it's at all permanent we have
our foreign policy also envisions the
communism is kind of an invasion of the
body snatcher type thing where uh one
once it takes over something it's got
you for good um
the world that i've seen hasn't borne
this out at all there are plenty of
countries that were once adopted a a
soviet influence system uh
basically held socialist ideals like
like ghana guinea uh tanzania egypt
are now great alive formerly their great
ally
somalia where
things have not worked out where because
of of conditions as they exist in the
country the country has gotten rid of
the soviet influence in ghana i was
there when they chased the soviets out i
ran them onto buses in front of jeering
crowds they took off for the airport the
soviet union didn't send an army in
there to keep kwame and crewmen in power
they couldn't have
and i think a similar situation would
prevail elsewhere where socialism has a
chance to work on its merits it usually
fails because it doesn't basically have
merits and people come to see this
we create situations where uh
people feel they have no alternative but
to go to the soviets for weapons
and speaking of weapons in central
america well there certainly are some
arms
i'm sure coming in
through nicaragua i don't think it's the
primary source of arms and certainly the
state department was quite wrong in
alleging in the white paper it issued
three years ago that uh soviet
intervention was responsible for this
rebellion obviously the local repression
is responsible but most weapons used by
most gorillas in the world today were
manufactured by the other side for use
in promoting the opposite purpose of the
afghan rebels are fighting with the
ak-47s that were produced to repress
them uh we read that in el salvador the
weapons that the nicaraguans allegedly
have sent in are
american
m16s that were sent over to vietnam for
use in fighting the opposite cause um
i love the irony also i i try to discuss
this again in in detail in endless
enemies the the irony that for both of
the alleged sides in the world their
primary bases in the third world were
built by the other their best bases in
the third world were built uh by the
other
the united states has uh uh its base for
defending uh the persian gulf in in
somalia a base that was built by the
soviet union
for their naval power whereas uh the
base the best base the soviet union has
which expands their power to the pacific
and gives them a base flanking china is
the base the united states built in in
cameron bay our guest this hour is
jonathan whitney who's a staff reporter
with the wall street journal and the
author of this book endless enemies
which was what we're going to be
discussing or have been discussing for
the last hour columbia south carolina
you're on the air go ahead please how
you doing this morning fine and yourself
oh pretty good have you had your coffee
and are you reading your paper well i
have a coffee but unfortunately i hadn't
seen the paper all right did you have a
question for our guest well comment in a
question i'd like to say he's very
articulate he seems to have a
significant amount of intelligence but
unfortunately he also seems to be very
confused
he keeps saying how he doesn't like
socialism and communism and he still
doesn't like capitalism and imperialism
uh unfortunately the state of utopia
does not yet exist and i don't think it
ever will because you'll never breathe
out of man
things that make utopia non-existent
which is greed fear
ambition greed and such as this
he keeps talking about all these
countries america has invaded and gone
into and sent into marines he also says
you know eventually the marines come out
guatemala and you know there's no
marines down in panama or down here
we're not keeping the government there's
certainly army in panama and by the way
i never said i opposed capitalism
well you sound like it to the people
that's looking at you on the tv
i mean you keep saying that neither
systems you know got what it takes to be
what you would consider good no i think
what i said was that the american system
of operating an economy is to my mind
from what i've seen in traveling in more
than 80 countries the best system on
earth we just don't allow other
countries to pursue it well
well i give you that but on these other
countries when you talk about able to
pursue things
we send marines in but we usually bring
them back out
i mean do you agree with that statement
too often dead well more than likely
sometimes the price has to be paid and
unfortunately that's one of the prices
caller let me ask you a question if i
could
earlier we were looking at a review of
mr whitney's book and it basically was
saying that
his book asserts that we support more
dictatorships than democracies in
central america do you think that's true
does u.s foreign policy support more
dictators than democracies
well in countries with the economic
background and the educational
background sometimes uh free related
governments are you know hard to come by
especially one that's not
jury rigged so even if you have an
election
uh you may not necessarily have a true
government in power like i say utopia
does not exist you can't go into a third
world country and just you know say hey
everybody let's go to ballot box vote
and we'll have a democratic society
that's a very good point you can't run
other countries why are we trying to do
that guatemala did have a working
democracy by the way
he's gone
we're going to have to be closing up
this hour at this point our guest for
the last hour has been mr jonathan
quitney as i said a staff reporter with
the wall street journal but the author
of the book endless enemies which is
what we have been talking about you've
been with the wall street journal for
the last 13 years a graduate with a
bachelor's degree in journalism from the
university of missouri a master's degree
in history from new york university
originally from indianapolis indiana mr
whitney thank you very much for joining
us thank you for having me here
but senator jesse helms said that the
cia had been contributing campaign money
to jose napoleon duarte to kind of
switch the balance in that election is
that an example of some of the things
that you're talking about
sure uh
i think
the whole situation in el salvador the
the political debate in the united
states over el salvador is basically
divided over how we are going to run el
salvador um
one side says that the most important
thing is to get rid of the the
communists and therefore we should do
that at all costs the other side says
well no we have to impose land reform
and human rights and we have to get them
to to we have to write some laws for el
salvador and get them to obey those laws
and then we can supply them aid um
the basic lesson i've learned and have
tried to set out in endless enemies is
that you can't run another country
better than it can run itself
jonathan whitney investigative reporter
with the wall street journal you have a
new book out called the crimes of
patriots a true tale of dope dirty money
in the cia what is it about
well it started out to be the story of
the new gen hand bank which was an
international organization
it had offices in 26 countries including
the united states there were a lot of
former military and intelligence
officials involved in
management of the bank it moved drug
money
moved about a billion dollars of black
money secret money
by people trying to cheat on their taxes
people like the marcos is trying to get
money out of
the philippines or or other third world
countries and was involved in drug
syndicates
it seemed to portray a kind of secret
network of u.s military intelligence
operatives uh it also
was involved in financing a couple of
operations for military intelligence
including the sale of some spy equipment
to iran and the sale of some weapons to
forces fighting in angola uh for
that the united states was supporting
how did this story break what happened
that
led reporters like yourself to uncover
these facts well i had followed the bank
from its collapse in 1980 when one of
the partners had his head blown off in
his mercedes uh and his
co-chairman a former cia operative named
michael hand fled
australia uh and a third partner bernard
houghton also fled australia in the
company of of thomas clines who later
reappeared as the deputy to general c
chord in the iran contra arms supply
network um
i covered the story for the journal
spent time over in australia and south
asia and norton wanted a book out of it
so i did the book and then last november
when the iran contra thing broke it
seemed to put the whole picture into a
different context and and i think
provided a context for the iran contra
scandal so i rewrote the whole thing all
last spring and into the summer when it
finally got hauled away into the printer
a number of the iran contra figures were
were involved in the book anyway c chord
was klein's was
shaklee
chichi quintero even the sultan of
brunei um
last
winter when we were editing the book
last november norton had suggested
taking the sultan of brunei out because
whoever heard of the sultan of brunei
and so forth and we needed to cut the
book
then last december he was on the front
page in the new york times in two column
headlines twice in one week and they
called up saying put the sultan of
brunei back in um nugent hand
at the show is the kind of context it
does set
brunei of course came into play during
the iran-contra hearings because when
the united states needed funding for the
contras after congress cut it off eliot
abrams had this sultan over here in the
far east who
could
be counted on to contribute 10 million
dollars well how did we get the
cooperation of somebody like that well
it turns out that newton hand had
contracted to set up his national
banking system and the internal
documents this was in the late 1970s and
the internal documents of new gand show
that the main criteria that the sultan
of brunei wanted for this international
bank for his national banking system was
that if his people ever rose up and
threw out this monarch that he be able
to get his private fortune uh out of uh
out of brunei and into some safe haven
like hong kong safely which was a
function nugent hand seemed to to be
able to provide and former admiral earl
yates who was the president of the new
gen hand bank was involved in
negotiations toward that end
so the suggestion or the thesis of a
book like this isn't so much than about
one bank in australia that was handling
dirty money but the suggestion that
there could be
other banks other ways of diverting
money from illegal to legal well there
have been and many of them are named in
there there have been international drug
networks that were really the byproduct
uh set up of of us intelligence
operations in fact the main heroin uh
factories in in the world were the
byproduct of u s intelligence operations
uh what i think i found and what what
the iran contra business seemed to put a
nice cap on
was that for 30 or 40 years not just
during the reagan administration
certainly since eisenhower
we've had an international network of
alumni if you want to call it generals
admiral cia personnel who were involved
in private businesses around the world
making money doing what they wanted but
also
who could be called on and were called
on for various covert
operations and what this has led to time
and time again is that the u.s taxpayer
the u.s government becomes the the cover
for vast criminal enterprises
fraud drug trafficking
tax cheating so forth
good morning and welcome to our program
our guest for the next 45 minutes here
today is jonathan whitney he's an
investigative reporter with the wall
street journal been with him for 16
years he's works out of the journal's
new york bureau and beginning in october
he'll have a half hour weekly news and
interview program on pbs he's the author
of
five books other books besides the one
i've already referred to most recently
endless enemies the making of an
unfriendly world graduate of the
university of missouri he's originally
from in indianapolis now more than
talking just about the book crimes of
patriots we'll get in a little more
detail about that this program if you
watch the show regularly is about
journalism and each morning at this time
we have a journalist on to talk about
issues but also how these journalists go
about doing their job
you have a very specific title
investigative reporter i've always
thought that title was was redundant i
think any good reporter is an
investigative reporter and uh
i don't know i think it's other people
who put that but isn't there a special
job assigned to an investigative
reporter and that you're giving a good
deal more time for one story and to
suggest you're getting sort of a little
bit more behind the scenes perhaps well
i mean one of the wonderful things about
the wall street journal is that it does
believe in providing the time and money
necessary to do any story
right and get to the bottom of it i
suppose i have a broader latitude in
that i don't have normal beat
responsibility and i'm kind of assigned
to come up with my own topics or be a
touching point for people who come in
over the transom with problems things
they see as wrong as as needing some
kind of remedy
something going wrong that is not being
handled by
the normal process of justice or or
correction so what do you do do you look
at the paper each morning looking for
for a scandal to investigate how do you
find your topics well
mail comes and phone calls come i mean
people call you and
tell you about things
far more of them than you can possibly
write about and
an awful lot of time is taken up just
hearing people that
will never resolve the result in a story
but they could result in a story so if
one out of ten does
and it's probably a lot less than that
uh you still need to hear people now you
refer to some very powerful people in
this book you talk a great deal
very former ci directors of the cia
representatives in the house of
representatives you're dealing with some
powerful people is it difficult to
investigate get information interview
find out facts about these kinds of
people well
i mean there there are difficulties and
uh
easiness is not not a word but um with
with uh any kind of person you're
dealing with uh the more powerful there
may be many more people who know things
about them and are eager to talk about
them it also may be harder to get to the
person himself
on the other hand uh when when
uh they see that something is actually
going to come out about them for example
this book was held up six days uh
actually on the loading dock the day the
trucks were pulling up to the warehouse
to ship
the first edition of crimes of patriots
general c cord's lawyer and theodore
shaklee and thomas kleins the former cia
officials
called up norton the publisher and
somehow had gotten a copy of the book
which was not authorized and claimed
that it was full of errors well
they were
kind of astounded because i had been
traced chasing these people for five
years trying to get any of them to talk
to me and they wouldn't so for six days
we went over their detailed lists of
complaints and
wound up with five or six very minor
wording changes in the book as a as a
result but no substantive changes
whatsoever and so a little fly fly leaf
insertion was was put in all those
thousands of books uh basically um uh
changing a few words here and there uh
to conform to what they had wanted
which was this yeah author's notes
crimes of past there there is no
substantive change and on the whole i
think it was testimony to how fairly
they really were treated in in the
original copy but anytime somebody's
willing to talk to you it's going to
result in
some change
improvement from his point of view um
improvement from everybody's point of
view because you want something to be as
accurate as absolutely precisely
accurate as you can humanly make it and
you need somebody's cooperation to do
that you get a little scared when you
find out that someone like general c
chord is
saying you're wrong um
no because i was pretty confident in my
research but you do want to go over i
mean
you're concerned because anybody can
make a mistake and i want to make sure i
didn't make a serious one we're
discussing two things this morning one
now what is it like to be an
investigative reporter and how do they
do their job and also jonathan whitney's
new book the crimes of patriots phone
lines are open for viewers in all areas
of the country if you have a question or
comment please feel free to give us a
call milwaukee wisconsin you're first
this morning go ahead please good
morning
the recent talk about raising the social
security really has me upset
i read the milwaukee
business journal every week and there
are two at least
at least one column sometimes almost two
of people who have not paid in
their social security all right
milwaukee i'm going to hold you there
we're not going to talk about social
security for this 45-minute period the
last show was about the budget process
we dealt with it a little so we're not
going to do it do you have a question on
the topic being investigative reporting
or the book crimes of patriots
if you don't i'm going to ask you to
give us a call when we have a show about
social security let's go back to the
book how many how many you said this you
spent five years working on all this are
there a lot of newspapers that give a
reporter that much flexibility and time
to work on well i i was doing a lot of
other things at the same time this isn't
all i did for five years um but in 1982
was the year i spent really
investigating it for the journal and
writing a series of of articles and then
in 1983 some investigative reports came
out of australia
and
that resulted in another series for the
journal and then
over the next few years in my free time
and working as the australian
investigative reports came out i
wrote a book let me read a paragraph
from the first chapter and it goes
beyond simply the
bank that you refer to in australia
quoting from your book the legitimate
security interests of the united states
certainly require a large and efficient
intelligence operation there are
powerful forces that nvr or oppose us
and we need constant up-to-date
information about them but the people
and organizations that make up what is
called the intelligence community in the
united states government have gone far
beyond the gathering of intelligence in
many cases the word intelligence has
been used as a cover for covert and
unconstitutional acts of war and civil
crime what are some other examples of
that that's a pretty serious charge well
uh
i mean here in nugent hand you have all
these top military intelligence
officials involved in a bank that
with
and everything in here is quite
documented the interviews are all on the
record the documents are available for
inspection if anybody wants to see them
they were running
massive amounts of money for the biggest
international heroin syndicates um and
when you trace it back the whole
golden triangle uh heroin
factory the where most of the world's
illicit opium have come from since the
1950s was the product of united states
operations to try to overthrow the
government of china after mao zedong
took it over and later to fight our war
in indochina
cia companies first sea supply
corporation later air america uh
actually brought the opium and heroin
out of the golden triangle helped the
chinese kuamentang army
the old nationalist army that was
invading china with our help in the
1950s this was all covert
helped them organize the opium growers
in the golden triangle this became the
main source of heroin in the united
states the main transshipment point was
marseille france the french connection
this also was the byproduct i i think
inadvertent i don't think anybody
intended this but
it resulted from a state department
operation to replace the leftist stock
union leaders in southern france because
we were afraid that in the event of a
crisis uh they would hold up american
shipping so we throw them out and bring
the corsican mafia in to run uh the dock
unions uh the result of this is the
institution of heroin laboratories and
the transshipment of uh heroin
on
the ships eugene oregon you're on the
air go ahead please
eugene oregon go ahead please
oh this is western eugene oregon
i'd like to know the answers well since
it seems that
this the uh cia is a big
huge
expensive program for the welfare of a
bunch of alcoholic bill pushers and
crooks
uh the few i've known are exactly in
that category you know
how does why doesn't congress have a
little control over it i asked that
question of peter defasion he couldn't
answer it
nobody knows where the money is in the
budget or who hands it out or anything
else it seems to me that there's no
reliability in congress anymore oregon
thanks for the call well this year maybe
a chance to do something about it i
think the the hearings we've heard this
summer aren't really auspicious that
things are going to change but um maybe
they still will after the negan hand
bank series appeared in the journal
the senate intelligence committee asked
for
help in looking into some of this stuff
and i prepared a list of questions for
them they held hearings uh into nugent
hand or said they did it was all closed
door stuff and i was later told uh by
the the chief counsel of the committee
that it
the
questions had been very helpful it was a
very important investigation but i could
never be told what the answers were to
me it's utterly incredible
and and the list of questions is an
appendix to the crimes of patriots and
they all deal not with something that is
truly national security
other than the fact that these people
have been generals and admirals and cia
people the questions deal with the
commission of crimes against american
citizens by other american citizens and
who is responsible for these crimes
50 to 100 million dollars was stolen
from the citizens of the united states
and allied countries and probably a good
deal more
through
absolute fraud they sold certificates of
deposit
and simply ripped off the money people
were told they were going to get high
rates of interest that the money would
be invested in money market securities
through normal banking practices there
was no investment no normal banking
practices they just ripped off the money
who's responsible for this why should
national security why should the fact
that these people are on on the one hand
in part of their lives engaged in
national security operations um be a
cover for the crimes they commit and yet
this has happened time and time again
the same things happened uh in the
contra war where
there's all kinds of evidence much of
which i present in here of of um the
contras operating off of drug dealing uh
off uh corruption and yet and there was
uh warnings of this the white house
certainly knew of it oliver north
certainly knew of it and the justice
department was informed of it for years
and yet did not act why should
a national security operation provide
cover for people who are committing
crimes baltimore maryland you're on the
air go ahead please yes uh you just
answered one of my questions but i did
have a second one um
[Music]
during the course of your investigation
uh could you comment on the drug
swallowing activities of theodore
shaklee and john c court out of john
hall's ranch
in costa rica and secondly
did you comment on a lawsuit i believe
by the kristic institute to prevent just
this type of activity thank you well
that lawsuit makes these allegations and
i want to say in fairness to theodore
shackley and general secord although
they come in for very heavy criticism in
this book
i think the allegations just made there
is no evidence to support them as they
were worded now i do say in the book
that theodore shackley was responsible
for hiring more drug dealers under the
payroll of the united states
than if he had simply gone out and and
hired the mafia uh which in the case of
the cuban campaign uh they actually did
but i don't think it was witting i i
think the um the i think shaklee has uh
inadvertently not by intent
brought on
criminals and
done things that were very
counterproductive to the national
security of the united states to allege
as the christic institute does that
these people intentionally set up a drug
dealing operation off of
the contra operation and particularly
the ranch of this man john hull he
mentioned
who was working with the cia if not for
the cia owns a lot of land in northern
costa rica by the nicaraguan border
which was used as a staging area for the
contra war
there just is no evidence to support
that and in fact
i went down and and measured the landing
strips at john hull's invitation
that are alleged by the christic
institute a couple of their witnesses to
have been used in these drug running
operations um hull insisted that
the planes they used could not possibly
have have taken off or that they say
they used could not possibly have taken
off uh from his airstrips and i i found
that the conditions down there the
measurements supported what he was
saying i just see no evidence for for
that lawsuit but that doesn't mean the
terrible things haven't gone on i've
also got documents which
norton on publication of the books
applied to members of congress showing
that
drug aircraft the aircraft of jorge
morales one of the biggest dope
smugglers in the united states uh the
main american end of the uh biggest
colombian cocaine cartel jorge morales
aircraft was
landed at illipongo air force base in el
salvador was refueled by the salvadoran
air force this is the main base the
united states uses to supply not only
the war in el salvador but also the the
contra
war obviously his aircraft we used there
i have on the record interviews with
with contras their names are named who
talk about the weapons being offloaded
from these aircraft the justice
department was informed of it
his profits as a drug smuggler are the
property of the united states taxpayer
millions of dollars
and yet this money was
funneled into the contra war had to be
with the knowledge of the u.s government
uh what's done about it seattle
washington you're next go ahead please
uh yes i wanted to ask questions
concerning the uh
the validity and the veracity of
journalism in the board hearings which
we've been listening to
it's amazing to me
how much the journalism plays in the
in the opinions of the legislative body
just the washington post
down the court real bad
but the wall street journal says he's
the greatest guy that ever you know
walked as far as the judge is concerned
the wall street journal or the wall
street journal editorial page in the
news sections or the editorial page well
the way it was portrayed over the uh
over the news it was just the wall
street journal said but the editorial
page which is a different operation
i doesn't that affect the validity and
the veracity of journalism
as a means of
of
legislative determination which
i i don't see why we don't throw the
live boats out and just give everybody
in congress and wall street
the washington post seattle thanks for
the call
well i i think if you
separate what is editorial comment from
news coverage if you were using his
examples only news coverage i think your
case evaporates do you have any examples
citing news coverage that would document
that he's gone
what about the the constant references
and hearings you do hear congressmen and
senators say i heard it in the wall
street journal or it's reported in the
washington post does that
give journalists more power than they
really should have
well no i mean what they're saying is
that these are facts everybody can't go
out and do
their own
reporting and and that's the function of
the newspaper uh
one presumes we're accurate at least the
vast majority of the time and we are
do you set out when you
you're looking at a scandal or something
that you're looking into do you set out
with the purpose of bringing somebody or
bringing an organization down
no i mean until something comes in over
the transom
you don't know that there's anything
wrong i mean the the couple of major
reagan officials who have resigned after
articles i've i've written
i knew
nothing about them one i'd really
confess i should have heard of but i
never i wouldn't have known his name
until somebody started bringing in
evidence
it doesn't come from malice and it's not
the power of journalists it's the power
of the information that the journalists
work and
go bring back
in most cases then are you only as good
as your sources are you only as good as
the people who give you tips and the
validity of those tips yeah and
but but tips are one thing uh i base
reporting on uh documents and on
interviews that are almost entirely on
the record rarely do i quote
anonymous people to to support a story
like that columbus georgia go ahead
please oh hello uh
i would like to know aren't you the
reporter that reported on geraldine for
our
parents being uh connected with that
mafia
and because i remember but you used to
have real bushy hair
i noticed you got it cut
but um i am that reporter
you had a report uh
i watched it on c-span
with all the reporters firing questions
at you the main thing i remember about
that was sarah melinda going to sleep
you know the
voice of a reporter from uh texas
actually sat there and slept through
that whole report columbus georgia
thanks for the call are you that person
uh i'm that person i'd like to thank my
hair cutter for
improving my image if necessary and i
hope the next time
ms mcclendon attends a talk i give it's
more exciting for her you do that often
give a talk where journalists will come
and listen um
yeah i guess so i mean investigative
reporters and editors is a wonderful
organization that
holds seminars and things and this group
asked me to come down and talk about
that story and i was glad to is that a
growing field investigative reporters
investigative journalists are there more
and more
newspapers television stations radio
outlets that are hiring people like you
um no i think probably the contrary
there was a big boom in it during the
1970s after watergate i think uh the
era during the reagan administration
really a pendulum has swung the other
way and
the press as far as uncovering new
material the flaws in what was being
presented
really backed off and got got a lot
quieter relied a lot more on what
government organs churned out what
reporting the news as the government
said it was i think since uh i think
since eugene haasenfuss's plane went
down over nicaragua last october 5th
there may have been a resurgence in it
fayetteville arkansas go ahead please
hello um
i'm i have a couple of questions first
of all i wonder
why the
while this reporter thinks the american
people aren't scandalized by
by some of these things
this isn't new because uh i remember the
same kinds of reports uh coming out of
the vietnam era when uh
cia was involved in some pretty large
drug operations over there uh
secondly uh i wonder if these uh
agencies you know of the government ever
run into one another in the uh uh in the
field out there dealing with this stuff
maybe uh
maybe they tried to arrest one another
or something like that i'd be interested
in knowing uh
you know if that sort of thing ever
happens oh yeah that's the way we found
out about some of these operations uh
much of the cia's
funding of private organizations was
uncovered in the late 1960s when a
congressional committee looking into tax
cheating and tax havens
suddenly turned up a bunch of
foundations that were
cia covers
and by the same token in the mid 1970s
an irs investigation
into a thing called the castle bank and
another thing called the mercantile bank
and trust company which were run
closely affiliated with the cia had
helped finance
anti-castro operations and
done other things for the cia in the
caribbean their cover was blown because
they were also operating as a way for
wealthy americans to cheat the irs out
of taxes so the irs is investigating
this operation and suddenly
runs across
the cia and
the investigation is kind of called off
the banks collapsed then uh in in uh
the case oh there was a one of the
biggest drug investigations in american
history in the late 1970s into an outfit
called the world financial corporation
in uh in miami and there were hundreds
of agents brought in from around the
country fbi and treasury and
irs
to
investigate this and they worked for
more than a year and suddenly the cia
found out that of the 25
prime suspects 22 of them were quote of
interest to the cia meaning they worked
for them the whole operation was
disbanded um many of the agents were
were really angry about it which is how
i found out about it hermaston oregon go
ahead please
good morning
i was wondering if the gentleman from
the wall street journal had ever talked
to senator boren
or senator hatch
or senator nunn
or senator cohen about his information
it seems to me
that he has a tremendous amount of
information
that certainly would be classified and
restricted
and the data and sources of his
information
would be quite important so i'll hang up
and
have him answer my question
why is it
classified why should it be classified
that there are a bunch of dope smugglers
operating uh
who also have signed up for some cia
work why does that entitle them to uh
national security protection for their
dope smuggling uh i don't understand
that i don't agree with it i know i have
not talked
personally with these senators i used to
deal with
nuns staff when he was on the senate uh
permanent subcommittee on investigations
but not on this matter
is classified documents this sheer
number of things that are classified
labeled top secret is that the the thing
you find your biggest roadblock and
being an investigative reporter thing
that keeps you from getting the facts oh
well
sure and and the fact is that that we we
again there we do need a spy operation
we do need secrets there are some things
that
absolutely should be classified but 99
of the stuff that is marked secret in
washington is
marked that way because it embarrassed
somebody because it's uh
politically they would rather it not
come out because somebody's career
somebody would be made to look foolish
because some bureaucrat is made to look
more important if his work is secret
than if you could really see what he's
doing not because of any legitimate
national security interest syracuse new
york go ahead please hi i've been
studying the topics that mr whitney
addresses in both his books for a couple
years now
and i found that there are crimes far
more serious than just the kind of arms
smuggling and drug smuggling that have
been
addressed today i mean there are
very serious programs of the cia that
have been responsible for the murder of
thousands of people
a major one probably the most public was
operation phoenix in vietnam
where director colby admitted to
congress that more than 25 000 civilians
had been killed in an operation led by
the central intelligence agency
there are also the death squads in el
salvador
who the cia admits they provide them
with information they give them
intelligence which in this case
only means that the names and addresses
of victims essentially
and of all the security forces in el
salvador that carried out the killings
the most feared was the national
security police the treasury police
together
who consistently tortured their victims
to death and it was discovered by a
reporter from the new york times that
the head of the national treasury police
the man named nicholas carranza
was on the cia payroll was receiving
ninety thousand dollars a year from the
agency
but what i what i would like mr putney
to address is the question of
what are the interests behind these
operations what
whose interests do these people serve or
do they think they're serving it's not
just about
all right we get the question syracuse
thanks for the call jonathan well this
caller is is quite correct it's not just
that carranza was on the payroll but the
united states government uh helped
finger some of the people that that they
went after which uh
i don't know what you can say about it i
have uh omitted talking about this kind
of thing because um it was mainly the
subject of the previous book endless
enemies and and the crimes of patriots
really went after uh crimes committed
against american citizens in in the
pursuit of this foreign policy rather
than the crimes committed against
foreigners but he's absolutely right um
operation phoenix killed not just twenty
five thousand but apparently more than
forty thousand uh civilians in south
vietnam it was totally counterproductive
to our interest because those are the
very people who would now be local
political leaders in south vietnam who
could provide some measure of
independence from north vietnam by
wiping out this layer of local political
leaders what we did was create a vacuum
which the north vietnamese
could could fill
in in the letters that i mentioned
earlier that shackley and c gordon
kleins had sent in to try to halt
distribution of the crimes of patriots
shaklee actually asserted that one of
the errors he he contended was saying
that operation phoenix was a violent
assassination program he claimed it was
a program to convert and and persuade um
uh local leaders and that it was uh uh
non-violent and that the deaths occurred
only in self-defense by the people
carrying out the program which is is
so
such an overwhelming untruth runs so
counter to to the evidence that you just
feel helpless trying to deal with it
honolulu hawaii your next go ahead
please
uh yes sir when you think that if the
congress would uh back
back to contras as much as i feel most
of the
american people do
that they wouldn't find it necessary to
deal in drugs in order to uh
back their uh their fighting
well i suppose an argument can be made
of that because the the main link i the
biggest link i found with an individual
drug dealer was made in 1984 right in
the summer right after the
uh congressional uh funding cut off on
the other hand
uh the kind of people who who deal in
these things i i think it the money was
not used just to fund the contra war a
lot of money went into people's pockets
quite obviously there are a lot of
contra leaders living very well right
now in san jose costa rica you go down
and and see their houses and uh
and and the notes that were
um
came out over the course of this summer
where rob owen in particular in
writing oliver north and others as well
told him about
people getting rich off this
i think they would have been doing that
and were doing it
anyway
not just to create money for the cause
but a lot of that money wound up in
people's pockets long beach mississippi
go ahead please
okay i have some questions about
investigating re reporting as to why
some of the republicans are not being
investigated
for example i have not heard very much
about dove divorce
very little mention about the short
period of time
between reagan's marriage and the birth
of their first child
i have heard a little bit about nancy's
alleged
birthday
and i did read a column in
kilpatrick over the weekend a biography
about hague
which mentions
that had
steady advancement in the military i'd
like to hear some comments about it
these sound like things that you would
investigate as an investigator no not on
the basis of what i just heard i i don't
know what he's talking about about about
hague that could be something but most
of the people are there many many
millions of americans have been through
divorce and unless uh unless he knows
something uh relevant to that situation
about it maybe something came out in the
divorce proceeding about uh bribes
kickbacks something but but without
evidence of that
to investigate uh whether years ago
somebody and i'm not even suggesting
that it could be true that somebody
might have had a child out of wedlock uh
this is irrelevant to the running of our
country we've today been discussing some
serious charges against powerful people
has your life ever been threatened in
the midst of an investigation
oh we once the um
uh a mobster uh tino deangelis once uh
made a threat and uh we printed it on
the front page of the wall street
journal uh the next day and uh he
profusely apologized uh
to my family myself
wrote letters um
i
i don't know what good does it do to to
i mean a journalist is not an eyewitness
to
anything he's relating the words of
eyewitnesses and so
like a prosecutor one goes and another
one comes are you ever worried about
that death threat um i only received
that one
back to the phones tucson arizona go
ahead please
you're on the air tucson uh yes
i would like to um
historical amnesia the book of politics
of heroin and south east asia
published in 1972
by abbott w mccoy
also the underground empire by james
mills
back in 1972 in that book they talked
about rcia making
agreements with corrupt portions of the
government in order to get a foothold
into the country
also the green gang in hong kong
tang kai shik and the money is taken out
of that country would you like to
comment on us sure um al mccoy in that
book uh the politics of heroin in
southeast asia was the source of much of
what i said the first source of much of
what i said about how we set up the
golden triangle heroin trafficking
industry as a means to support our
anti-communist wars there and one of the
things
i did in researching the crimes of
patriots was to go over his
material and show how absolutely right
he was i've got people in the drug
enforcement administration
on the record admitting that that mccoy
who was dismissed as uh
really a fringe stuff back then mccoy
was absolutely right mccoy knew more
about what was going on over there than
than anybody else i've got
eyewitnesses who verify what he said it
was a a brilliant book columbia south
carolina go ahead please
oh
good good morning good morning i would
like that
caller start over again we missed the
beginning what you had to say okay
uh
good morning again okay i would like to
ask
maybe a little bit but let's turn them
on
can you hear me better now sure can go
ahead
i would like to ask a reporter there
about this uh rural peace
organization
i was watching it last night
and it was documented on
pbs
that it is
funded
by the russian disinformation corps
and operated by the kgb has he looked
into that
um
i never heard of it uh until this minute
uh certainly the kgb uh uh tries to
spread full stories as does the cia try
to spread false stories abroad um
both of them are a disservice to the
truth you try to
document what you hear
and i'll stand by the accuracy of an
independent documentation of what i've
written this one organization i never
heard of
san diego go ahead please yes sir mr
quinn mr clinton would you comment on
the charges by h ross perot and vogue
writes of the mias that secretary
assistant secretary of defense armaturaj
is involved in drug trafficking i
i hate to hear stuff like that even
said on television
and
just as i felt very uncomfortable with
what a previous caller said about two
former cia officials
i have criticized these people for a lot
of things but barring
that the other caller was asking about
which tends to be affiliated in many
minds with with um more to the left of
the spectrum and people like greitz and
perot who tend to be affiliated more to
the right of the spectrum have come upon
the same conspiracy theory and yet i
have
begged and pleaded for independent
documentation something corroborable
to support what they say and so far they
they just basically say trust us and i
can't do that as a reporter and i don't
like to hear allegations being spread
that don't have documentation about them
when it's really character assassination
what are you working on now are there
one or two items you're looking at i'll
never ask a reporter a question nah
like that uh
when i've got it and it's solid i'll
print it
are you working any other books that you
can talk about no um i've got a
television series starting up i felt a
little overwhelmed uh
the television series started in new
york last spring and i intended to have
this book out of the way before it did
um instead the iran contra thing broke
and uh between that and and trying to uh
well
fortunately i was doing a lot of
reporting for the journal on that so it
tended to dovetail but uh
my family gets neglected and and i just
have uh decided to drop out of books for
a while to
do these other things our guests for the
last 45 minutes has been jonathan
whitney investigative reporter with the
wall street journal and the author of a
new book called the crimes of patriots a
true tale of dope dirty money in the cia
jonathan whitney thanks for joining us
thank you
in a few moments we're going to be going
to a live hearing up on the house side
of the u.s capitol specifically it's the
house energy and commerce subcommittee
on health and they're going to be taking
a look at pending legislation dealing
with aids and sharing it will be
representative henry waxman a democrat
of california that hearing is a little
late in getting started so jonathan
clinton can stay with us for a few
minutes more we'll continue a discussion
of his work as an investigative reporter
and also author of this most recent book
and some of the topics we've been
talking about for the last 45 minutes
what is the impact been the iran country
hearings and a look at this money being
brought in from outside sources outside
governments to fund a secret
government operation with this much
publicity of something like that what
has the impact been on the cia and
perhaps other operations like this that
could be going on well we don't know yet
and that's one of the things that's
going to be fascinating to find out what
the congressional committees are going
to report in their report i think
what it's important for the public to
understand and then the main point i was
trying to bring out here is that the
iran contra problems the idea of these
private organizations
making money on the one hand
working secret deals
on behalf of american
on behalf of the white house that are in
complete contradiction to what our
stated public policy is
this kind of problem was not invented by
the reagan administration it is not a
result of mismanagement in this white
house
as the tower commission unfortunately
suggested it's the result of policy that
has been going on uh for at least 35
years maybe 40 years in this country
the quote i open the book with is from
harry truman who in 1961 looked back
over this organization the cia that he
had created 14 years earlier and saw how
far off track it had gotten and called
for all this to come to a halt
it did not come to a halt and for the
cia to go back to its original purpose
of being a quiet efficient intelligence
gathering arm a network of spies that
would keep the president informed uh and
yet
the ability of the cia to do that is is
really hampered by uh this high profile
business of of organizing private
mercenary armies all over the world
which is what it's been doing lynchburg
virginia go ahead please hello you're on
the air oh
isn't this moralist that uh
the reporter is speaking uh
isn't he the uh
uh
person that was identified
in an exhibit
that they mentioned 75 76 and 77
that was mentioned by one of the
senators from virginia as being
a partner of c chord and isn't he in
custody and
supposed to go to trial in uh
somewhere down in i think it's day
county
or orange canada and florida jonathan
whitney um
morales is in jail beginning a 16-year
federal term in florida uh i know of no
meeting that ever occurred or
conversation that ever occurred between
him and richard c cord
nevertheless richard c cord is running
an operation to arm the contras and the
contras who are
up to their neck in that operation who
are directly under the supervision of
the cia and the north
uh white house network that c chord was
working with um
we're dealing with with morales and
north had every reason to believe that
the justice department was uh was
informed of it and yet
they seem to accept that as as the price
we pay for uh the covert war fullerton
california go ahead please
yes i uh i'm just sitting here watching
mr putney and
wondering what
damage to our intelligence gathering
capabilities
will further occur by
his kind of investigative reporting uh
you know we cannot survive in this world
without investing investigating
reporting around
investigating some intelligence
operations as well as reporting
but uh you know i
people like mr clinton here are so
protected by this wonderful government
this wonderful constitution and yet
uh are continually going forward throat
and
yes
as oliver north said in his hearings
you're not dealing with boy scouts when
you're trying to gather intelligence in
foreign countries
and uh the cia uh sometimes has to do
these things so does the kgb the only
difference is that mr putney is
protected by our uh
bill of rights to do what he does
whereas
uh his equal in
pravda or uh
you know a task
[Music]
thanks for the calls the first amendment
give you this kind of blame um i love
this country very much and consider
myself unbelievably lucky to have been
born here and to have this country
our
press freedoms are
unique i think most americans don't
realize how much freer
we are under our constitution than even
the allied countries we tend to think of
as being in the same bag
and i think
this is is the very thing that that
makes us a a strong country is that we
are able to find out what our government
is doing
i don't think it's necessary that the
cia run drugs or be involved in drug
running operations
i don't see that the national security
interest
necessarily requires it and if it does
then let people judge it on the basis of
the facts i think the public in this
country i think the the whole spirit of
the constitution and the bill of rights
the whole spirit behind our system of
government is that
only when when uh the public is aware of
what their government is doing can it
determine whether that is right or wrong
and i don't think most people are aware
of the amount of crime that has been
committed under the aegis of of our
covert operations over these years uh if
they're willing to accept
we haven't even mentioned the contract
murders in here
if they're willing to accept all this
as as a price for it
i'm not here leading the political
campaign or
moral crusade
but i think they deserve to know what's
going on and i think that is the essence
of the reason the first amendment is
there
in this the 200th anniversary of the
bicentennial of the constitution
how do you see the status of the first
amendment are you seeing a move more
stricter definition is it broadening is
it just right what do you see the
evolution of the interpretation the
first amendment 1987 oh i think long
range first i i don't see a a real trend
one way or the other i sure wish that
libel litigation nuisance libel
litigation were
more restricted in this country
and
so that
the least mistake
cannot be compounded into suppressing a
book such as endless enemies actually
was suppressed for more than a year due
to an unusual circumstance of a
publisher's bankruptcy and the libel
action which
after a couple of years was thrown out
of u.s district court is completely
without merit but as a result of it for
two years nobody could read what the
pulitzer prize committee said was the
second best non-fiction book
written in in 1985 and i i feel that uh
the power of those kind of libel actions
to
just beleaguered journalists and they do
intimidate a lot of smaller newspapers
from from running the kind of reporting
they should be running but this is a
long-standing problem and while i'd like
to see things get better
i don't think they're getting worse
grand meadow minnesota go ahead please
yes i'd like
i'd like to know what happens to all of
the uh
the drugs and the money found during a
drug bust
well supposedly it's impounded by uh the
police um there have been cases in the
past uh where where uh the drugs
disappears police have made money uh one
interesting episode
is that a major contra figure uh who was
arrested um uh with one of the largest
cocaine seizures maybe i think it's the
largest in west coast history a couple
of years ago
the money that was seized with him was
all which is taxpayer money is as drug
profits was all given back to him
when a couple of contra supporters come
to contra leaders in uh in costa rica
who who my name in here uh
wrote a
letter to the u.s justice department
certifying that the money was actually
contra funds that had been given to this
drug dealer a guy named zavala to buy
supplies for the contras well later
these contra leaders at least one of
them
admitted to a reporter in costa rica
that he was lying when he said that to
help his friend zavala that actually it
was not contra money it was drug
proceeds and yet because of the contra
connection
the justice department gave the drug
money right back to the drug dealer
our guest this morning is jonathan
quitney he's an investigative reporter
with the wall street journal and we're
discussing his most recent book the
crimes of patriots in a few moments
we'll be going live to the house side of
the u.s capitol for a hearing taking a
look at pending legislation dealing with
aids fullerton california go ahead
please
hi hello you're on the air fullerton uh
what i wanted to know was whether or not
he i just tuned in a short time ago so i
don't know if he's talked about anything
about what what's going on in the
philippines and whether the cia or
anybody like that is connected with us
[Music]
what's going on in the philippines right
now is something uh i'm dealing with and
i'm uncomfortable talking about it until
i'm ready to produce it journalistically
the bank that you in the new game bank
that you were talking about in australia
did that deal with a lot of people in
southeast asia the philippines you
mentioned oh yes
it was headquartered in australia based
in austin the main office was in
australia but it operated in 26
countries and one of the main original
ideas of it was to help people in
wealthy people in southeast asia get
their money out of
shaky governments
in indochina for example and then later
a lot of these governments like in
thailand and malaysia in the philippines
have currency restrictions because
they're trying to keep capital in so
that the money that's made in that
country stays in that country for
the investment there and the benefit of
the people and yet
uh wealthy people want to get it out to
hong kong to switzerland and so forth
and negan hand was set up in part as a
means for them to do that and the bank
took large fees merely for
transferring funds from one country
illegally in into another lexington
massachusetts go ahead please
uh yes mr kwitney
i would like to suggest that
would you do something
to expose
the left wingers in the united states
doing
illegal
things you seem to concentrate more on
the
people associated with the right way
like geraldine ferraro
i mean if you've got something uh tell
me what it is
i'll be glad to give you my phone number
uh um
have you found that you've read more
about republicans and democrats
um
no i don't think so uh
much of the work i did during the 1970s
was about labor unions uh which were
then affiliated with the democrats i
guess the teamsters have now gone over
to the republicans as a
last refuge but
if he's got evidence of criminal
behavior um on a large enough scale to
be noteworthy uh i've got no litmus test
about uh
writing about it what kind of letters do
you get you say you get all these tips
what kind of letters do people send you
what do you hear well you get a whole
spectrum
a lot of people cheering you on thanking
you for doing it
some people scrolling in crayon over
what you've written calling you
names and
the most important kind people who
uh say that they've been witness to some
kind of wrongdoing that they want
straightened out and that they're going
to trust you with it our guest jonathan
whitney investigative reporter with the
wall street journal thank you very much
for joining us thank you
ms billington and his thoughts about
what the future of the information age
means for libraries
about books saturday nights at 8 eastern
and pacific
and sundays at 9pm eastern end pacific
next jonathan quintney talks about the
life of pope john paul ii including his
views on religious issues and the role
he played in ending the cold war
this recent biography of the pope is
called man of the century
jonathan whitney is the author of eight
books and was a writer for the wall
street journal for 17 years
he spoke about his book at saint peter's
church in chicago
[Applause]
good afternoon
well in a sense pope john paul ii is
probably the best known person in the
world
and you probably already think you know
the salient facts about him but if
you're like most people
like i was before i went to work on this
book
many of the most important things you
think you know about him are wrong
so some of what i'm going to say here
may startle you and from time to time
you might think well boy i wonder if he
could supply proof of that
in man of the century
678 text pages and another 75 or so of
notes and index i think i have provided
proof of what i say from fully
attributed eyewitness accounts
and quotations from documents
many of which have never before seen
public light and often in the pope's own
words
to illustrate let me take his attitude
toward women which is a matter of great
concern to catholics and others in the
united states although to me it seems a
relatively minor point overall
through his public and his private deeds
john paul has pushed the catholic church
farther toward gender equality and
toward a feminist agenda than it has
ever been
obviously that's quite a contradiction
from his public image
much more important i think is his vital
role in the conduct and resolution of
the cold war the single greatest
struggle of our era and in its aftermath
in world politics
his work which ended the cold war with a
peaceful victory for freedom
spanned decades not just his time as
pope
this work has been completely
misreported until now and because of
this the central history of our time is
poorly understood
your own chicago historian gary wills
whose work i otherwise greatly admire
has actually written at length that the
pope is a mystic a non-political person
who would have played no part in
political activities i i think i will
persuade you otherwise
i really think that in four and a half
years going on five that i've been doing
intense research i have come to know
this man about as well as anyone but
perhaps his longtime secretary and maybe
a few others i've interviewed more than
a hundred people who have known him at
close quarters for long periods of his
life and i've interviewed many of them
practically to the point of exhaustion
over multiple days
i've interviewed hundreds of other
people who have known him and read
written recollections from more than a
hundred others i've combed through his
old letters at the homes of friends
and spent more than a year's
concentrated time in libraries
reading the hundreds of thousands of
words he has rented has written
i've quoted at length in man of the
century selected passages from his
writing that should convey his thoughts
clearly
john paul has probably published more
words than any other man who ever lived
and yet his style is often difficult and
this accounts i think in large part for
why he so poorly understood
if you would ask most people for example
what his greatest changes have been in
catholic doctrine they would probably
say these changes had something to do
with sexual repression
in fact his main writing on sex uh a
book published in 1960 which he has not
departed from in his frequent remarks
since then
modernized and liberalized existing
church attitudes towards sex his book
shocked many in the roman curia uh he
advocated female orgasm he insisted that
the pleasure of both parties was an
essential element for acceptable sex not
just openness to procreation
more importantly he rooted his sexual
ethic in a really innovative expression
of the dignity and equality of all
humanity rather than in the moralistic
scolding which had been the focus of
church teaching until then
john paul's sexual teaching thus became
a major tool that he was able to use in
subtly fighting totalitarianism and
materialism
and by the way i should make clear that
i don't agree with catholic attitudes on
birth control or on the ability
of women to take top leadership
positions in an organization
these attitudes are among many reasons
that i am not a catholic
but this pope should be judged on what
he has done and not on church law that
he inherited
john paul's striking departures from
existing church policy
that i can find are three
first he rejected the
just war doctrine that has prevailed
since the day of saint augustine in
favor of an almost absolute pacifism
next his policy of respectful outreach
to non-catholics to try to increase the
role of spirituality in human affairs in
a truly non-sectarian way this is
something that
pope john the 23rd hesitantly advanced
but that this pope john paul has boldly
promoted to the consternation of many in
the church
lastly is his assertion that the church
has an obligation to acknowledge errors
and apologize for them
now one could debate how perfectly he
has instituted these policies
and man of the century contains a number
of instances in which i think he bungled
very badly but if you look at the record
i don't see how you can question either
the sincerity or the energy that he
expended in trying to institute these
ideas
i've been asked to limit my opening
remarks to allow plenty of time for
questions and i will answer them as long
as as there is time so i want to use the
balance of my time now to talk about my
main theme my main story my main purpose
in writing
and after all i'm not a catholic
my main purpose is to tell
not just how this man resolved a crisis
for the whole world
but how
by exercising a level of character and
fortitude and dedication to pure
principle that i would not have thought
possible in a human being until i
studied him
he provided an example of how any of us
could change our world
regardless of the odds
and never did any person face greater
odds than carol voitiwa the future pope
who has been shot at numerous times
since childhood including by the german
army who has suffered hardship so
harrowing is to practically defy belief
to americans who have been told for
decades that our government budgets have
to be consumed by military expenditures
beyond what we can imagine or account
for
non-violence may seem a very naive idea
even if it's a noble one
but john paul's success in using it
against a greater power than even martin
luther king or mahatma gandhi had faced
with it is a stunning example
of popular attitudes toward john paul's
role in history have been shaped largely
unfortunately by hoaxes
and it has recently been a source of
great frustration to me that the news
outlets in the united states and
elsewhere that spread these hoaxes
are now unwilling to correct them
most salient is the hoax advanced by the
writer carl bernstein and what i from
what i've learned about his methods now
i will no longer call him a journalist
on the cover of time magazine on the
cover of reader's digest in a
best-selling book a purported papal
biography called his holiness on
numerous television shows principally on
nbc
he said that john paul was engaged in
some sort of holy alliance with
president reagan to pursue by covert
means a shared policy that brought down
communism and this story is now commonly
believed
i think my detailed fact finding on
pages 445
through 449 of man of the century
should destroy bernstein's credibility
permanently
what he says is refuted by virtually
everyone he claims supports his
assertions
most vividly for example i remember
archbishop archbishop bronislav
dombrowski in warsaw who according to
bernstein traveled regularly to the
united states to plot this so-called
holy alliance in meetings with cia
director william casey and the white
house aide general vernon walters
when i asked archbishop dombrowski about
it
i feared that he is an elderly man and
from the way he looked he was becoming
ill he left the room and came back with
his passports and passionately turned
page after page in front of me uh
declaring that he had not been in the
united states since 1975
he had never met casey or walters and
that these stories were completely
untrue
his face was read as he denounced quote
the slanders of that american quote
quote
referring to bernstein
and said that he had written in vain to
european newspapers that had reprinted
uh these assertions uh demanding a
retraction which he never got
by the way general walters uh the only
other living witness to these meetings
uh also flatly denied them to me walters
gave me what seemed to be a full and
unbelievable account of his limited
dealings with the pope which can contain
nothing of any holy alliance as
bernstein described
bernstein has proven similarly wrong at
every turn
yet time magazine will not correct its
record by printing a word about my book
by way of news or review despite
requests nor his readers digest
nbc won't provide air time to correct
its disgraceful misinformation of the
public
and yet you'll find in man of the
century abundant proof
that rather than help the pope's
non-violent revolution the reagan white
house turned its back on solidarity and
as i'll explain in a moment even tried
to kill it
another american biographer of pope john
paul tad schultz adopted his his thesis
the deceitful story given him by general
wojtek yarizelski the polish communist
dictator
to the effect that jurasewski and john
paul worked as allies throughout the
1980s to bring down communism
the same archbishop dombrowski that i
referred to a moment ago supplied me
powerful evidence that quite in contrast
to what tad schultz wrote yarazelski was
personally responsible for the murder of
pope john paul's devoted ally father
jerzy papialushko a polish hero in 1984.
man of the century also reveals that the
polish communists almost murdered
cardinal voitiwa's assistant father
andre bardetsky
in an attack that voitiwa said was meant
for him just months before he was
elected pope this is the first time that
attack has been disclosed in the western
press
the phony thesis of an alliance between
john paul and general yarazelski put
forward by this other biographer tad
schultz
made the cover of newsweek as well as
prime network television
and yet newsweek and the others have not
corrected this error so far despite many
requests
an even more extreme hoax was put
forward by the late journalist claire
sterling saying that italian prosecutors
had overwhelming evidence independently
verified that the soviets through the
bulgarian secret police were responsible
for the gunshot assassination attempt on
pope john paul ii in saint peter's
square in 1981
sterling's work was advanced on the
front page of the new york times and two
full pages inside
in one of the longest and most
influential articles that the times has
ever published without even a trace of
skepticism about the truth of the story
rarely has the times been so unequivocal
about anything the story also made the
cover of reader's digest and a full hour
of nbc special white paper in prime time
but in man of the century you can read
for the first time the account of the
italian prosecutor who tried to
prosecute this case against the
bulgarians and now concedes that every
bit of it is untrue
every bit of the evidence put forward by
the new york times reader's digest and
nbc widely repeated by the entire press
is untrue and there is no evidence
whatsoever that the soviets or the
bulgarians were behind the assassination
attempt
both of the papal biographies i
mentioned earlier bernstein's and
schultz's accept the truth of the
bulgarian connection hoax as do other
popular histories
and yet will the new york times or
readers digest or nbc correct the
deceptions that they propagated
the times in nbc are well aware of my
book but they have not corrected the
record uh except in a
buried uh paragraph in one book review
i'm going to plead with you now
both those listening to me here and
those listening over c-span and thank
you very much c-span for for being here
i'm going to ask you to look at the
evidence
fairly
unlike the authors of these other books
i am not quoting
uh
cia documents i'm not quote or
unidentified cia sources i'm not quoting
the self-serving accounts of american or
communist politicians
man of the century
offers the fully attributed words of
direct participants
uh from hundreds of interviews mostly in
poland because that is where the central
events that ended the cold war took
place
i'll say something now again that may
startle you but i want to ask you to
look at the evidence not claims from
washington
but evidence on the ground in eastern
europe
i know it's always dangerous to play
what if with history
but i think the evidence suggests that
if carol voitiwa had not become
archbishop of krakow there would have
been no solidarity and if there had been
no solidarity the soviet empire would
still be running in 1997.
would communism have fallen without
carol voitiwa
well i ask you to read pages 590-594
of man of the century about that
british colonialism in india probably
would have fallen
eventually without mahatma gandhi and
jim crow would probably have been erased
in the united states without martin
luther king
and communism probably ultimately would
have ended uh for one or another of its
failures
but ultimately is a long time and it
could be a bloody time and in this
nuclear era it could have been a
cataclysmically bloody bloody time these
men gandhi king
and voitiwa john paul
were really pivotal in what they did
maybe voitiwa john paul most of all
the now declassified documents from the
highest communist bodies and in man of
the century i quote the scholars who
have examined these documents and some
of them i've read in translation myself
they show that the kremlin leaders were
not consumed as we have been taught in
trying to match president reagan's
military buildup
they were certainly bothered by their
blunder in afghanistan
and the american response which was
ordered by president carter but the
soviets were truly consumed for decades
with the threat of the non-violent
revolution they saw growing out of the
polish church and the notion that this
revolution would spread as it did
throughout eastern europe and the ussr
itself and yet they could not stop it
i repeat don't just listen to my words
read the evidence
we've been taught for years that the cia
is what recreated the underground press
and radio in poland bernstein and former
cia director robert gates in his memoir
last year still say this
i think i have accounted in man of the
century for all of the main underground
press outlets in poland
and the radio transmitters
they were the work of poles some of whom
went to jail for it and most of those
polls
conceived themselves that they could not
have done that work except for the
achievement
and the protection provided by two
decades of carol voitiwa's
administration of the church as bishop
of krakow
dozens of leaders of underground
solidarity who were responsible for
these underground print and radio
outlets insist on the record that they
received no help whatsoever from the c i
a and that they were incensed and still
are at the very notion that they did
these leaders tried repeatedly to get
help from the american government which
refused them
uh miroslav hoyetsky the father of the
polish underground press was actually at
the white house the weekend martial law
was declared in 1981 this has never come
out before on a trip to seek aid for the
underground press and the white house
brushed him off it gave him nothing over
the next few years desperate for money
the solidarity leadership unable to get
anything from the united states actually
tracked down an afghan guerrilla leader
a guy named masoud in order to persuade
him
or try to to divert to poland some of
the billions of dollars the united
states was funneling to the afghan
rebels the afghan turned them down
president reagan even refused the
request of solidarity leaders to pose
for pictures with them to make it more
easy for them to
raise private funds
quite to the contrary what the u.s
really did was try to persuade the
afl-cio president lane kirkland who was
solidarity's best friend in the united
states
to help restore normal commercial
relations between the u.s and communist
poland by killing solidarity
and recognizing instead the stooge union
that the communists hope to set up to
replace it
and former secretary of state lawrence
eagleburger who is the man kirkland said
was sent to him to deliver this message
won't deny it
he says it's probably true
if that's hard to believe
try this the communists in their efforts
to destroy solidarity were helped not
only by the united states government but
by cardinal joseph glemp the primate of
poland who was consistently not a
supporter of solidarity but a thorn in
its side
all these people badly lacked the vision
of victory that was within reach as one
man carol voitiwa pope john paul ii knew
lacking that vision the u.s and lecture
himself all tried to sell out solidarity
to the stooge union
one man stopped the communists in their
efforts to kill solidarity the pope in a
series of personal interventions in 1983
and 1984 that are described in detail in
man of the century
with first-hand sources
you will read how the pope confronted
and backed down general yarazelski in a
stunning private meeting and then a few
days later burst in to disrupt another
private meeting between yerezelski's
emissaries the communists and cardinal
cassaroli the vatican secretary of state
who also was afraid of what john paul
was doing in stirring up this revolution
and wanted to help the communists
restore normal conditions
yet
as critical as voitiwa was
to solidarity's victory i don't think he
ever saw himself in the role of a
political leader
the remarkable and inspiring hallmark of
this entire story
is that he reversed world history merely
by dedicating himself
to well thought out principles including
non-violence and respect for the dignity
of worth of every human being even those
who did not respect him
and he set out from youth to live his
life that way
at each turn he simply tried to advance
in whatever small way he could what
elements of justice were available to
him
if you were to set a beginning for the
revolution that overthrew communism i
think it might be the day in june of
1953 when carol voitiwa a young priest
who had just received his doctorate in
philosophy
climbed two flights of wooden stairs
in an office in downtown krakow that i
was also able to climb
to the newspaper to god nick pouchny
church-sponsored semi-independent
newspaper in krakow
that had just been put out of business
by the soviets in a repression following
stalin's death
voitiwa had contributed poems and
theatrical reviews to the newspaper
arriving now in this time of turmoil he
tried uh he listened to the editor tried
to describe to him the feudal efforts to
get the paper restarted by the
communists
voitiwa just asked the financial
condition of all of the editors and
their families who had been thrown out
of work in this repression
told
things were tough
he pulled out his pay envelope and put
it on the desk of the editor
to be distributed to the families in
need
this gesture of giving his own money
church money to help
what were in essence the non-violent
rebels of poland
uh impressed so many people a number of
other priests then followed suit and the
bishop
30 years later in the time of solidarity
this example set an example
for thousands of polls who remembered it
and contributed their own money to help
the solidarity fugitives and their
families by repeating voitiwa's gesture
that first pay envelope he gave wasn't
large
but man of this injury recounts how as
he rose to bishop and then archbishop
he secretly passed much larger envelopes
of church cash to those who would use it
to sustain the rebellion this continued
when he was pope during times of
solidarity
some of the funds that were passed by
priests close to voitiwa for use by the
polish underground large amounts of them
were stolen from the vatican bank by
thieves involved in a major notorious
international bank scandal
all these stories are attributed to
eyewitnesses and participants
i interviewed who have never talked
about these matters before
shortly after he climbed the stairs back
in 1953 to deliver that first pay
envelope of cash to the resistance
voitiwa published his first book
at the risk of imprisonment not just for
himself and the printer but for anybody
who was caught with a copy of it this
volume 250 copies of about that many
pages hand pressed over typed matrixes
had been lost to history until someone
introduced me to that original printer
back in 1953 who showed me his own
preserved copy which has been verified
for me by the vatican
the portions you will find reprinted in
man of the century
are amazing for several reasons there
are a specific blueprint for conducting
a non-violent revolution in almost the
same language that was used a decade
later by martin luther king in the
united states but they also contain an
endorsement of elements of marxism that
criticize capitalism
they spell out a recipe for a catholic
social welfare state that is radically
different not only from communism but
from utopian capitalism that is promoted
now by politicians who have tried to
claim john paul for their ally
john paul as i show by quoting his
speeches over the decades into the mid
1990s has continued to espouse the same
social welfare ideas ever since
he is a staunch opponent of utopian
capitalism
which as
has been the emerging primary value of
mankind since he helped in ways i will
now show uh end communism
in 1960 soon after voitiwa became a
bishop
an editor of a magazine he oversaw
introduced him to a czechoslovakian
couple who had managed to get government
approval to cross the border into krakow
and travel there and approach the church
secretly as a result of that meeting
voitiwa began secretly preparing for
priesthood candidates from
czechoslovakia the decimated
czechoslovakian church where where most
of the priests and bishops were in
prison
uh these candidates would sneak across
the mountain border into poland to uh
begin their training and sneak back
again voitiwa established a smuggling
network to bring study materials to them
in czechoslovakia
this has never come out before he began
secret highly illegal ordinations in
poland of czech priests and then bishops
and then similarly secret illegal
ordinations of other bishops uh other
priests candidates from around the east
block particularly in hungary and
ukraine under his direct supervision the
smuggling network grew throughout the
east block involving laymen and well as
priests whom i've interviewed you'll
find in man of the century their
personal attributed accounts the
contraband they brought included
literature and political journalism
as well as religious materials much of
this material was printed by a former
philosophy student of voitiwas who set
up a publishing company in paris to
smuggle the goods back into poland at
one point a whole boxcar load of this
contraband these smuggled materials were
shipped to co-conspirators within the
soviet union itself with bribes paid to
some soviet soldiers
more than once voitiwa disguised himself
in civilian poland civilian clothing and
in great danger to himself crossed the
mountains daringly into czechoslovakia
and hungary for a first hand look
also of great importance was the church
synod he started in krakow
modeled after the church synod suggested
generally during the second vatican
council but he turned his synod into an
empowerment tool for thousands of
catholic intellectuals who had
previously felt powerless and atomized
under the system many of them grew into
the leadership core of the movement that
became solidarity
voitiwa turned his krakow synod into a
virtual shadow government gaining
substantial leverage with the communists
and quietly training the intellectual
core of the resistance movement
he began holding secret highly illegal
communication seminars for rebel leaders
some of whom were only recently freed
from prison when they sneaked to krakow
or or some other destination to attend
he used his philosophy classes and other
personal contract contacts to train the
cadre that became solidarity a good
example is the case of podan sivinsky
who first met voitiwa by asking to go
along on one of the famous canoe trips
voitiwa led as a young priest savinski
canoed and skied with father and then
bishop voitiwa for decades and was his
philosophy pupil
eventually zavinsky became chief editor
of one of these two seditious
pro-liberty magazines that voitiwa kept
alive in krakow against constant threat
his preservation of the only
semi-independent lively press in the
entire communist bloc may be his single
most important contribution and these
publications came under threat not only
from the communists but from
traditional elements of the catholic
church in their censors who considered
them to socialist
the other magazine the one not edited by
savinski was edited by another protege
of the pope's tadeus mazavitsky who
later became the first post
post-communist prime minister of poland
both sivinski and mazavietsky revealed
for the first time in interviews from my
book that it was carol voitiwa the
cardinal in private meetings who
persuaded them to lead a pivotal hunger
strike that propelled what became the
solidarity revolution
and it was this hunger strike that
inspired lectureensa to join the labor
union that uh voitiwa's followers were
organizing i call it in the book the
boston tea party of the polish
revolution
savinski and anthony masiarevich another
rebel whom voitiwa had been encouraging
in private meetings then told me how
voitiwa had put the polish church behind
a flying university a series of illegal
public political meetings that followed
the hunger strike and it was only the
church's risky patronage of these
meetings that made them possible and
they began just months before he became
pope
all this is what led to the public
recognition
two years later of the labor union known
as solidarity and of the solidarity
revolution that overthrew communism
solidarity though meant much more to
carol voitiwa than just a union that lek
valencia was elected president of
it was an idea
an idea he espoused through his
underground 1953 book on catholic social
welfare
it was subverted
this idea within a year of solidarity's
victory in poland in large part by the
very western politicians who love to
portray themselves as voitiwa's allies
this tragic downfall of what voitiwa had
fought for so long
constitutes the last part of man of the
century which i am have entitled
judgments
but i've now spoken long enough on my
own and i want to take
questions uh as long as you want to ask
them
i would like to know what you attribute
this conspiracy of the press
uh to
i call it catholic bashing it's the best
i can come up with it but you know if to
think that nbc and all of these major
forces would not tell the truth it's
rather staggering well
i wouldn't call it a conspiracy i don't
think they set out to tell what was not
the truth some people
offered
stories which which
were hoaxes i mean there's no other word
for it and i think the the proof is is
there that they were hoaxes uh these uh
news outlets went out on a limb on their
own uh on these hoaxes uh embraced them
and it is not very comfortable to say
that your
not just a minor story you report but
your cover story your big lead in the
new york times the story that you really
made your own is all wrong i mean it's
it's hard to admit that and that's the
only thing i i can attribute it to i i'm
not a mind reader i hope that these news
outlets will start paying attention
now
well i don't think there's another
religious leader or political leader or
any kind of a leader of our time who's
comparable
to the pope and this man is is a giant
among popes
as well as among others
yes
i i don't know of i would not have
imagined going into this book that there
was a human being who could be quite
this great i i just stand in awe of him
my uh
i probably would have said that the
currents of history have much more to do
with making
allegedly great men than the other way
around but
this has persuaded me otherwise
yes in the
i'm
back
i i guess you are aware
that there are many intellectual
luminaries
non-catholic who have become
catholics
among them are
arnold toenby
gilbreth keith chesterton
dave brubeck
and our very own chuck gowdy
and i i personally
would like to invite you
to become a catholic
i thank you very much for the invitation
i decline
yes
how many communications did you have
with the pope or did you just rely on
all investigators
well
uh
the vatican press office
and its director joaquin navarro walls
who is one of the three or four people
closest to the pope took a personal
interest in this and i think
they must have discussed how they were
going to treat me i mean the the pope
knew what i was doing
and i think they decided that
navarro vols would be the intermediary i
was allowed to submit written questions
through him and some oral questions some
of which would come back answered and
some of which more of which would not
come back answered but uh
that's the way they decided to handle it
i'm glad to have had
that much access
i i long
in my heart for reasons behind besides
merely fact gathering to meet this man
who has become so important
in my life and whom i've come to respect
so much
um
he gave about six hours of time to
another biographer tad schultz and the
vatican and and the pope were extremely
disappointed with the use to which that
time was made in the biography
and i think that helped determine that
i was going to have to deal through one
layer of
of intermediary
yes
what can you share with us about what
you've learned about the pope's prayer
life either as it progressed through his
through his vocation or as it stands now
and are you aware of any stories or any
connections with any miracles that might
be associated with uh the pope
well my whole book is about a miracle
that that
the
communist empire
could have fallen
peacefully non-violently successfully
would have been denied in in washington
even a year or two before it happened
even after solidarity and i think i show
in man of the century that solidarity
was really running poland beginning in
1986 it was over
nobody could quite say that because the
soviet union was there the communist
party was there
solidarity
if it began to make too much noise
openly
might have lost ground rather than
gained it but they were running poland
opening up the free enterprise
and yet even then in the west it would
not have been thought possible
in 19
in the 1960s uh when brezhnev came in in
the 1970s during the brutal crackdowns
under martial law in 1981 uh it was a
miracle what the pope did to
and again the source of the miracle
i don't want to get into that
as far as his prayer life
i think even catholics even cardinals
are impressed that this is the most
prayerful and uh
i'm searching for a spiritual man uh
person
they've ever encountered uh from
childhood
uh schoolmates would tell how everybody
had to go into the church and genuflect
once on the way to school and they were
all running and all late and fast they
did it voitiwa was always there
praying uh
as others came in and as others left
throughout his life he he would pick
places within
a catholic church
not the main altar but some special spot
wherever he he was going whether it was
a new uh place to go to school or a new
town he was
a priest in or or wherever
a private prayer spot that he would go
to over and over and people would see
him
in that spot for hours
this after he became pope um
churchman who had dealt with other popes
uh
remarked on how frequently after every
meeting
or meal
he would take them into the chapel
to pray
he had
this is a very powerful element in his
life it's uh
again as a source of awe to me
thank you
let's uh let's thank mr whitney for this
presentation today
thank you
but certainly uh he has certainly
convinced me to read this book uh the
startling
things that that he mentioned today uh
shows us how easily we can be
misled and and swayed into different
opinions that may not be based on any
facts or on any reality
mr whitney will be at the back here now
signing copies of his book for anybody
who wishes that and
i'm sure there are more questions that
you may have that you can address to mr
whitney here i i want to thank you for
coming here today and for sharing in
this very special presentation god
[Applause]
thank
bless
i have a lot of boston the reporters
here that are going we we are the
eternally hopeful and uh
and prayerful and uh don't that's at 8
pm eastern and again at 11
next jonathan whitney author of the book
man of the century pope john paul ii and
the demise of the soviet union he spoke
yesterday at a forum hosted by the
woodward-wilson international center for
scholars in washington his remarks and a
question and answer session last just
over an hour
oh
i'd like to welcome everyone to our
first session uh in isn't noon
by the time we get done
like to welcome everyone um the first
session of 1998 it's kind of hard to
believe it's january it's so nice
outside um
so i i thank you all for uh
coming back inside instead of staying
out in the victorian garden and enjoying
the sun
we have our next event will be next
monday at noon when carlos pasqual who's
director of russian ukrainian and
eurasian affairs the national security
council will be speaking on ukraine in
1998
certainly with ukrainian elections
coming up it's a it's a time to focus on
ukraine
and then on thursday january 15th uh
nicholas danilov from northeastern and
william orem executive director for the
committee
to protect journalism uh which is based
in new york uh will speak about the
state of freedom of the media and
azerbaijan and armenia
and that's it january 15th of 3 30.
my experience
here has been that some of the
most memorable presentations have been
made by authors who have
recently finished books
they actually have figured out what it
is that they want to say and and say it
very well
um so i'm i'm very pleased to
be able to present uh jonathan whitney
who is author of this
very handsome new biography of pope john
paul ii he just mentioned that he saw it
at the train station today so if it's
available in train stations it's
available uh in bookstores uh near where
you are
um i think it's not surprising that he
is the author of a book that
is widely available he was a reporter
for the wall street journal for
nearly two decades before he moved on to
pbs
where he hosted a weekly national news
program the whitney report
that um
actually coincided with the collapse of
communism in europe and therefore in
addition to all the domestic
subjects that were covered
the show spent not a small amount of
time on the collapse of communism
uh he's written for harper's atlantic
new republic readers digest the nation
esquire
and
he's the author of endless enemies which
was a runner up for the pulitzer prize
in non-fiction in
1985. he's author of the best selling
book the mullendore murder case which is
about the killing of oklahoma
socialite and rancher e.c
mullendore ii
uh certainly
i think many of you know his reporting
from his days with the wall street
journal he's won a number of awards for
his writing i mentioned
his runner-up um
for in the pulitzer
competition he was also winner of the
george polk award the cindy hillman
award the olive branch award
he's a native of indianapolis and then
he
received his bachelor's of journalism
from the university of missouri from the
fine journalism school there and went on
and received his m.a in history from nyu
so
i
welcome him and again please look for
the book when when you leave
at your nearest train station if not
nearest bookstore
thank you
well
can you hear me um
my appearance here today is something of
an accident that i hope you will find it
a happy one despite my cough which i
can't help and i've medicated myself
against as best i can
i'm here today because i happen to be
reading the new york times last fall and
found an article
saying that the wilson center had sent a
delegation of scholars to warsaw for a
conference on
the events of december 13
that was the weekend
when martial law was imposed on poland
in an attempt to kill the solidarity
revolution
and since this was a historical episode
that i had just researched the hell out
of for my new book
interviewing everyone i could track down
most of whom
had not spoken out about it before
i wondered if the scholars who were
going to warsaw were at all aware of
what i had found
i became even more perplexed when i read
in the times that the conference had
failed to resolve issues
which i had thought i had already
resolved very much thank you
quite satisfactorily along with many
other previously unresolved matters
probably of interest to cold war
scholars as i'll get to
so i immediately telephoned friends who
had been scholars at the wilson center
and asked to whom there i might make
myself and my information known
and about five phone calls later i was
on with joe drezen who was gracious
enough to extend this invitation and i'm
grateful to him and to the cannon
institute and to each of you for coming
one of the most remarkable aspects of
the new york times article i read about
the wilson center conference on martial
law in poland was that it did not even
mention the man most responsible for
there being a solidarity revolution in
the first place and without whom that
revolution certainly would not have
achieved
its stunning victory that man is pope
john paul ii
in a sense the pope is the best known
person in the world and you probably
think you already know the essential
facts about him
but if you're like most people
and like i was before i began research
on this book
many of the most important things you
think you know about john paul are
probably wrong
and so some of what i'm going to say may
startle you today and you may wonder
if i have any evidence that it's true
well in man of the century which is 678
text pages and another 75 pages and
notes and index i think you will find
the proof in eyewitness accounts and
documents many of which have never
before seen public light
of what i'm going to say
in nearly five years of intense research
i really think i came to know john paul
about as well as anyone but his longtime
secretary and maybe a few others
i've interviewed more than a hundred
people who have known him at close
quarters for long stages of his life and
interviewed many of them practically to
the point of exhaustion over several
days
i've interviewed hundreds of other
people who have known him in more
limited ways i've read the writings and
recollections of more than a hundred
others
i've combed his old letters at the homes
of his friends and spent more than a
year's intense time in libraries reading
his millions of printed words
john paul has probably published more
words than anyone who ever lived but his
style is often difficult and his
thoughts on political and social matters
are often intertwined with the message
of his religious office
and so he's often misunderstood
in man of the century i've tried to
isolate his writings on particular
subjects quoting his own words but in an
isolated way that i hope will convey his
thoughts more clearly
and to illustrate take his attitude
toward women which is a subject of of
great concern about him in the united
states
in his public and private actions john
paul has pushed the catholic church much
farther toward gender equality and
toward a feminist agenda than it ever
has been
obviously that's quite a contradiction
to his public image
to many people the church's two thousand
year old ban
on women priests remains unforgivable
but it's clearly a catholic doctrine and
not a john paul doctrine
if you would ask most people what john
paul's greatest changes in catholic
doctrine have been they probably would
say it had something to do with sexual
repression
in fact his main writing about sex in a
book in 1960
and he's not departed from the views
expressed in that book in his numerous
talks on the subject since then
it may surprise you that the views in
this book modernized and liberalized
church attitudes towards sex
the book shocked many people in the
roman curia uh specifically advocating
female orgasm saying that acceptable sex
required the pleasure of both parties
not just an openness toward procreation
and more importantly he rooted his
sexual ethic
in a truly innovative philosophical
exposition
about the dignity and equality of all
humanity
not in the moralistic scoldings that had
characterized church teaching on sex
before that
and in this way john paul made his
teaching on sex a tool in his fight
against communist totalitarianism
and against capitalist materialism as
well
and i should make clear at this point
that i personally do not agree with the
church's
position on birth control on the ability
of women to fill leadership roles in
organizations and on a lot of other
things which is why i am not a catholic
but as a non-catholic author i try to
keep myself neutral on church issues of
business to catholics but which i don't
think are my business
i do think though that the pope should
be judged by what he has done and not by
what he inherited in the way of church
law
now john paul's striking departures from
the church policy he inherited are three
and it may surprise you what they are he
has rejected the just war doctrine that
has prevailed since the day of saint
augustine
and come out in favor of an almost
absolute pacifism and said there is no
such thing now as a just war
he's reached out respectfully to
non-catholics to try to cultivate more
spirituality in life in a truly
non-sectarian way
and lastly
he's asserted for the first time that
the church has an obligation to
acknowledge errors and apologize for
them
now one may debate how well he has
instituted these policies and man of the
century cites a number of areas in which
he has bungled rather profoundly but if
you look at the record you cannot
question how sincerely and energetically
he's tried to pursue these policies
much more important however is his
central role in winning a peaceful
victory for freedom in the cold war the
great struggle of our era that is the
reason i wrote the book that is my story
and that is the obvious interest of most
of you here
his non-violent revolution that ended
the cold war spanned four decades not
just his time as pope
of course tens of millions of polls can
take credit for this work and i don't
mean to deny it to them but to a
remarkable degree
carl voitiwa who became pope john paul
ii
inspired and organized the forces that
eventually became the catholic
intellectual clubs which he helped
organize
then core the committee for defense of
the workers and then
what grew out of core solidarity
he gave them the moral fortitude the
legal protection and often the money and
materials they needed to succeed as well
as most importantly his example
of course he couldn't have done it alone
and many polish americans and other
americans
contributed leadership and financial
support in the dark days of a seemingly
invincible soviet rule and worked with
such polish americans as cardinal john
kroll of philadelphia and archbishop
alfred abram abramovic of chicago both
of whom were important sources for my
book
but one man was indispensable
if you were to set a beginning for the
revolution that i believe overthrew
communism i think it might be the day in
june of 1953
when young father carl vuittiwa a young
priest climbed two flights of wooden
stairs in downtown crack out of the
office of tagonic pauscheckney a
church-sponsored semi-independent
newspaper in krakow that had just been
put out of business by the soviets
voitiwa had contributed poems and
theater reviews to the paper but now in
this time of turmoil after the death of
stalin he listened to the newspaper
editor describe
the feudal attempts the editors had made
to get the communists to allow them to
restart publication
voitiwa waved off all the political talk
and simply asked about the financial
condition of the editors and their
families who had been thrown out of work
hearing about this he pulled out of his
pocket his own pay envelope that he had
just received put it on the editor's
desk and act
asked that it be distributed to those in
need
this gesture inspired a few other
priests and a bishop to do the same and
it was so dramatic that it was widely
remembered thirty years later in the
time of solidarity when many priests and
other polls imitated voitiwa's example
um through that for that that first pay
envelope he distributed by the way by
the nineteen eighties takan nick
pauschechny thanks to bishop cardinal
voitiwa had
been resurrected and was publishing
again weekly
that first pay envelope that voitiwa
donated was not large but man of the
century chronicles how as he rose to
bishop and then archbishop he secretly
passed much larger envelopes of church
cash to those who would sustain the
rebellion and this continued during the
time he was pope when large funds were
passed by priests close to voitiwa for
use by the polish underground often
money that had been stolen from the
vatican bank in a notorious
international bank scandal by thieves
and all these stories come personally
quoted from people who actually gave and
received envelopes among others and who
have not talked about it openly before
shortly after he climbed those wooden
stairs to deliver that pay envelope to
the rebellious editors he published his
first book
at the risk of imprisonment not only for
him and for the underground printer but
also imprisonment for any readers caught
with a copy
250 copies of this book were hand
pressed on typed printing matrixes
thousands of pressings to produce 250
copies and this volume entitled catholic
social ethics was lost to history until
my researcher
in poland located the underground
printer who had preserved his own copy
and showed it to me and it was verified
for me by the vatican
this book was a manual for organizing a
just society among other things it set
down rules for a non-violent revolution
in language strikingly similar to that
used just 10 years later by martin
luther king in the united states
and while there were only 250 copies
they were seen by people who would play
a large part in solidarity
soon afterwards in 1960 after voitiwa
had been appointed a bishop he was
introduced to a czech couple who had
come to krakow on some business pretext
and as a result of that meeting bishop
voitiwa secretly began preparing
czechoslovakian priesthood candidates to
stock the decimated czechoslovakian
church of course
the communist governments strictly
controlled the priesthood and so all
these activities were highly illegal
students were sneaked across the
mountain border into poland to begin
training and then sneaked back
voitiwa established a network to smuggle
study materials into czechoslovakia and
this was the real beginning of charter
77 which would have continuing links
with the intellectual group around
voitiwa uh throughout the uh
1970s and 80s
voitiwa began secret and highly illegal
ordinations of czech priests and then
bishops and then similar
secret illegal ordinations of priests
and bishops from elsewhere in the east
block particularly hungary and ukraine
under his direct supervision the
smuggling network grew throughout the
east block involving not only this
secret network of priests but also
laymen
uh the contraband included literature
and political journalism as well as
religious materials
much of this contraband was printed by a
former student of voitiwas who went to
immigrated to paris and set up a
publishing shop there to print matters
that would be smuggled back into poland
at one point a whole boxcar load of this
contraband was shipped successfully
to conspirators in the ussr through
poland with bribes paid to soviet
soldiers there
more than once bishop voitiwa disguised
himself in civilian clothes and crossed
the mountain border at great risk in the
czechoslovakia and hungary for a
firsthand look at this organization
his underground printers train the
underground printers elsewhere
and in
my book man of the century will find the
first hand stories of the people who
live these stories also of great
importance was the church synod that
voiti was started in krakow modeled
after the church synods that were
suggested generally during the second
vatican council but voitiwa turned his
synod in crack off into an empowerment
tool for thousands of catholic
intellectuals who had previously felt
powerless and atomized during the long
reign of communism
many of these synod leaders grew into
the leadership core of the movement that
became solidarity
voitiwa turned his crack off synod into
a virtual shadow government gaining
substantial leverage with the communists
while quietly training the intellectual
core of the resistance movement
he began delivering secret and highly
illegal communication seminars for rebel
leaders some of who came there directly
from jail
where invitations were were sneaked to
them by emissaries
voitiwa used his philosophy classes and
other personal contacts to train
solidarity's future leaders
a good example is bogdan sivinsky who
first met voitiwa on one of the famous
canoeing trips that voitiwa led as a
young priest which were also really
training grounds in citizenship and
ultimately in non-violent revolution
zavinsky canoed and skied with father
and then bishop voitiwa for decades and
was his philosophy pupil eventually
savinski became chief editor of one of
two seditious
and pro-liberty monthly magazines that
voitiwa kept alive against a constant
threat
and voitiwa's preservation of this
semi-independent semi-free press the
only one in the entire communist bloc
was probably his most important single
contribution to the revolution
and it's worth noting that these
publications came under fire not just
from the communists but also from
traditional elements in the church that
considered them to socialist
which he was other magazine the one not
edited by savinsky was edited for two
decades by
tadesh mazavietsky another protege of
voitiwas who later was elected the first
post-communist prime minister of poland
both savinsky and maza vyetzky revealed
for the first time in interviews for man
of the century that it was their patron
voitiwa who in private meetings
persuaded them to lead as they did the
pivotal saint martin's hunger strike in
1977 that propelled what became the
solidarity revolution it was this hunger
strike that uh directly inspired lek
valensa to join the labor union that
uh cardinal voitti was other uh
followers were organizing this hunger
strike that voitiwa instigated was in
effect the boston tea party of the
polish revolution
sivinsky and another rebel voitiwa had
encouraged in private meetings anthony
matziarevic told me how voitiwa had then
secretly put the polish church in in
more private meetings with them had
secretly put the polish church behind
the flying university
these were a series of illegal but
public political meetings that got
underway justice voitiwa was elected
pope in october 1978
and only the church's very risky
patronage of these meetings made them
possible
all this is what led to the public
recognition two years later of the labor
union known as solidarity and of the
solidarity union
that overthrew communism
now of course none of this is the story
that's commonly accepted in the west the
central history of our time
a non-violent revolution in the face of
a military standoff is misunderstood
to americans who have been told for
decades that our tax money needs to be
consumed by huge military expenditures
the idea of non-violence may seem naive
so it's all the more stunning how
successfully john paul used non-violence
against adversaries that were greater
in power even than those faced by
mahatma gandhi and martin luther king
the point of this story is not just how
carl voitiwa changed the world by
exercising a level of character and
fortitude and dedication to principle
that i would not previously have thought
possible in a person
but also
the point is to show how by the example
he lived
any of us
could also change our world regardless
of the odds and no man or woman ever
faced stiffer odds than carl voitiwa
who's been shot at
not just the once that is famous but
often since childhood many times by the
german army in occupation he has
suffered hardship so harrowing is almost
to defy belief
and yet in contrast to what i've been
saying popular attitudes toward john
paul's role in history have been shaped
largely by hoaxes and it's recently been
a source of great frustration to me that
the same news outlets that spread these
hoaxes are now unwilling to correct them
most salient is the hoax advanced by the
writer carl bernstein and knowing what i
now know of his methods i will no longer
call him a journalist
bernstein says that the pope was engaged
in a holy alliance with president reagan
to pursue covertly a shared policy that
brought down communism
this fantasy which is now commonly
believed was advanced on the cover of
time magazine the cover of reader's
digest in a best-selling purported papal
biography called his holiness
and on numerous television shows
surely my detailed fact finding on pages
449 the 445 to 449 of man of the century
should destroy carl bernstein's
credibility permanently
what he says is refuted by virtually
everyone he claims supports his
assertion
for example bernstein reported that
archbishop ronna schwab dombrowski of
warsaw traveled regularly to the united
states during the 1980s to plot this
so-called holy alliance in meetings with
cia director william casey and the white
house aide general vernon walters
when i asked him about it archbishop
dombrowski an elderly man
left the room uh bright red i feared he
was becoming ill and came back with his
passports and passionately turned the
pages at his passports in my face
proving
he said that he had not been in the
united states since nineteen seventy
five he had never met casey he had never
met walters and general walters the only
other living witness to these alleged
meetings also flatly denied to me that
they had ever taken place and flatly
denied to me that any such alliance as
bernstein described had ever taken place
archbishop dombrowski this elderly and
lovely old polish gentleman told me he
had demanded retractions from newspapers
that had printed bernstein's assertions
and
couldn't get them
i now share his frustration
although bernstein has proven wrong at
every turn time magazine hasn't
corrected its record by devoting one
word to my book by way of news or review
nor his readers digest
another american biographer of john paul
tad schultz adopted as his thesis the
tale given him by general wojciech
yarazelski the polish communist dictator
to the effect that it was not reagan and
john paul but yarazelski and john paul
who worked as allies through the 1980s
to bring down communism
i found powerful evidence that quite in
contrast to what tad schultz wrote
yarazelski was directly responsible for
the murder of the pope's devoted
supporter father
yerzi papialusko in poland in 1984 and
many other attacks on the pope's priests
man of the century also reveals for the
first time the story of father andre
bardetsky
voitiwa's longtime assistant who was
nearly murdered by the polish communists
in an attack that voitiwa said was meant
for him just 10 months before voitiwa
was elected pope
the phony thesis of an alliance between
john paul and jarazelski made the cover
of newsweek as well as primetime network
television
will newsweek and others correct their
errors so far they have not despite many
requests and they are well aware of my
book
in another direction the noted historian
gary wills a catholic has written in
many prominent journals that the pope is
a religious mystic who would never have
anything to do with politics and never
wanted anything to do with politics this
of course is equal nonsense
a classic hoax was perpetrated was it
was popularized by the late journalist
claire sterling who said that italian
prosecutors had proof that independently
verified evidence showed the soviets
through the bulgarian secret police were
behind the assassination attempt against
the pope in saint peter's square in
1981.
this story was advanced across the top
of the new york times and two full pages
inside without a trace of skepticism as
to whether it was true the story twice
made the cover of reader's digest it was
the basis of extensive prime time
network news
exclusive documentaries reporting it as
if it were fact
well in man of the century you can read
for the first time the account of the
italian prosecutor who tried to
prosecute this case against the
bulgarians he now concedes that every
bit of the evidence put forward by the
new york times readers digest various
television outlets every bit of it is
untrue there is no evidence that the
soviets or bulgarians were behind this
shooting
both the rival papal biographies i
mentioned moments ago uh bernstein's and
schultz's generally accept the truth of
this bulgarian connection hoax as do
other popular histories written recently
so far none of the major press outlets
that carried the story have seen fit to
correct it
i ask you here to look at the evidence
fairly
unlike
the other stories that were so widely
publicized mine does not rely on
unidentified cia sources or the
self-serving accounts of politicians
either american or communist
man of the century offers the attributed
words of participants
mostly in poland because that is where
the events that ended the cold war were
centered
the real story of this polish-led
revolution needs to come out
i know it's always dangerous to play
what if what if with history
but the evidence suggests
that if carl voitiwa had not become the
bishop of krakow there would have been
no solidarity and if there had been no
solidarity the soviet union would
probably still be operating in 1998
would communism have fallen without carl
voitiwa
that is a complex question and i treat
it as a complex question on pages
590-594 of man of the century
but i think british colonialism
eventually would have fallen without
mahatma gandhi
in india i think jim crow probably
eventually would have ended in the
united states without martin luther king
and eventually i think communism was
doomed for one or another of its
failures but eventually is a long time
and it can be a bloody time and in the
nuclear age it can be a cataclysmically
bloody time
and these men gandhi king and voitiwa
john paul did make a critical difference
voitiwa john paul maybe most of all
now was a large military capacity by the
united states needed to deter the soviet
union from using force to impose
communism on western europe which
certainly would have made voitiwa's
revolution much more difficult
the history of polish
excuse me the history of soviet policy
certainly suggests that an american
deterrent force was critical
but did an expansion of that force by
presidents carter and reagan hasten the
demise of the soviet empire appreciably
as most people believe
there seems to be scant evidence of that
many of you are far more expert than i
and the matter i'm about to discuss and
so correct me if i'm wrong but according
to the experts whom i consulted and who
are quoted in my book the
now declassified documents from the
highest communist bodies
show that kremlin leaders were not
consumed as we have been taught with
trying to match president reagan's
military initiatives they were certainly
bothered by their enormous blunder in
afghanistan and by the american response
to that which was ordered by president
carter
but what the soviets were consumed with
for decades was the threat of the
non-violent revolution they saw
growing out of the polish church
spreading
the notion that this revolution would
spread as it did throughout eastern
europe
and into the ussr itself
and yet they could not stop it
don't just listen to my words here
please read the evidence we've been
taught for years that the cia is what
created poland's underground press and
radio
for solidarity bernstein and former cia
director robert gates still say this
but they don't cite a single specific
example
man of the century accounts for the
specific examples of all the main
underground press outlets under
solidarity and the radio transmitters
these were not the work of americans
they were the work of poles many of whom
went to jail for it dozens of leaders of
underground solidarity who were
responsible for these underground print
and radio outlets have insisted on the
record
that they receive no help whatsoever
from the cia and they are absolutely
incensed at the suggestion that they did
most of them acknowledged that they
couldn't have done their work without
the leadership and protection that was
provided by carl voitiwa during two
decades as bishop of krakow and later
pope
these solidarity leaders tried
repeatedly to get help from the american
government and they were refused
miroslav hoyetsky the father of the
polish underground press was actually at
the white house the weekend of december
13 1981
the weekend of martial law on a trip to
seek aid for the underground press he
had been sent there at the suggestion of
voitiwa's long time protege tedesch maza
vyetsky
he was brushed off at the white house
with nothing
over the next few years the solidarity
leadership desperate for money even went
so far as to track down an afghan rebel
leader a guy named masoud to try to
persuade him to divert some of the
billions of dollars that the united
states was giving to the afghan rebel
leadership to open up a second front in
in poland the afghan rebel leader turned
solidarity down president reagan even
refused the request of the solidarity
leaders to pose for pictures with them
which they thought might help them raise
private funds more easily
the truth is just the opposite of what
we've been told
in fact
the u.s government actually tried to
persuade solidarity's best american
friend afl-cio
then president lane kirkland to help
kill solidarity and thus restore normal
commercial relations between the u.s and
communist poland
kirkland was asked by former secretary
of state lawrence eagleburger to
recognize instead the replacement union
that withdraw support from solidarity
and we
recognize instead the replacement union
that the polish communists wanted to set
up
which i refer to as a stooge union in
the american term
if that is hard to believe that the
united states did this
also believe
the communists were also helped by
cardinal joseph lemp the polish primate
who was consistently a thorn in
solidarity's side
and whom the pope consistently had to
deal with
glem
and the united states tried to close
down solidarity in favor of the stooge
union
and more than that lechva lewenser
joined them
what caused glenn
the united states lek vuensa all to try
to close down solidarity in favor of a
communist stooge union
in
1983-84 they lacked the vision of a
victory that was actually within their
reach
one man stopped the communists in their
effort to kill solidarity the pope in a
series of personal interventions in
1983-84
described in detail in man of the
century
you will read how he confronted and
backed down general yarazelski in a
stunning private meeting and then a few
days later burst in unexpectedly to
disrupt another private meeting between
yerez eltski's emissaries
and cardinal cassaroli the vatican
secretary of state supposedly the pope's
number two person at the vatican but who
also sought to help the communists
restore normal conditions
no
i don't think that the evidence will
substantiate the common myth that
president reagan's policies won the cold
war
there is of course one other man whose
policies are often
said to have brought about the end of
totalitarianism and the cold war mikhail
gorbachev
interestingly it was gorbachev not
reagan who kindled in the pope a
response that might have led to
something like a holy alliance
although gorbachev still called himself
a communist it was gorbachev's new
policies not reagan's that the pope
thought might create a bridge
offer a bridge to his own catholic
social ethics
now i'm not evaluating whether this is
necessarily a correct analysis of
gorbachev's program but it was the
pope's analysis
probably also on john paul's mind was
his transcending desire to bring
orthodox russia back to the catholic
church
uh later after communism
collapsed uh this desire to reunite the
catholic and orthodox churches led john
paul into a rash plan for expansion of
the catholic church into the former ussr
a plan that backfired badly in the 1990s
another factor prompting john paul's
predilection toward gorbachev was the
pope's self-identification as a slav
something he has never let anyone forget
for a moment
an identification that became intense
during his youth as an actor
and as a student of slavic culture
at any rate from this combination of
motives john paul did extend gambits to
gorbachev several times in the mid 1980s
and when these were unsuccessful finally
in 1988 he wrote gorbachev a
deliberately warm letter hand delivered
in moscow by two of the pope's closest
aides
uh proposing that the two men meet and
move to reestablish russian soviet
vatican relations
this proposal from the pope which has
remained secret for years may have
offered gorbachev his last real hope for
success in his effort to reform the
solid the soviet union without losing
control of it then even more than now
the pope could be an imposing moral
figure on the world stage and gorbachev
could have had him as a substantial
public ally
in exchange for concessions on religious
freedom and on poland that gorbachev
wound up making any way later
that the pope was sincere in this offer
became particularly clear two years
later during the crisis in which the
baltic countries sought independence
from the ussr
in the midst of this crisis the pope
specifically praised perestroika and
publicly encouraged the baltic countries
with their large populations to
cooperate with gorbachev's reform
program rather than push gorbachev into
a crisis in which he might feel
compelled to use military intervention
a year after that in 1991 the pope
openly endorsed gorbachev's leadership
during the coup attempt that pushed
boris yeltsin into power and sealed the
fate of the soviet union
an endorsement of the kind that john
paul gave to gorbachev was unprecedented
by the pope for a political leader even
in catholic countries
yet back in 1988 when gorbachev's
political life might have been
salvageable gorbachev lacked either the
courage or the wisdom to take the pope
up on his offer of a meeting
gorbachev's story is one of several
instructive dramas during the cold war
in which political leaders
with considerable courage
showed that their courage stopped just
short of what was necessary i also
recount in man of the century the
stories of president kennedy and premier
khrushchev who while hardly cowards
either one
were presented with a chance that they
understood could lead the world out of
the cold war
in a direction that they knew was right
in principle and a chance that pope john
xxiii wanted very much to help them take
but at the critical moment both kennedy
and khrushchev bulked adventuring down
this new path that might have made them
appear weak before their domestic
enemies they decided they had to move
gradually in order to preserve the power
that would they thought let them move
more forcefully in later years
but as with gorbachev the power that
kennedy and khrushchev
declined to risk
in order to follow a principle that they
knew was right
this power did not last them very long
anyway
only one world leader
pope john paul ii beginning as karl
voitiwa walked unequivocally and
unapologetically down a new path that
led to a peaceful resolution of the
totalitarian era that has blighted this
century
he walked down this path against
constant opposition all around him not
just from political leaders but from the
power structure within his own church
and as the details of his story show he
was not pushed along by events instead
he constantly pushed events along he
constantly pushed and prodded poles
forward at numerous times when they were
about to give up or be sold out
yet
as critical as voitiwa was to
solidarity's victory i think it's
important also to note that i don't
think he ever saw himself as a political
leader
the remarkable and inspiring hallmark of
his story is that he reversed world
history merely by dedicating himself to
well-thought-out principles including
non-violence and the respect for the
dignity of every person whether or not
that person respected him
he set out early to live his life by
these principles
he planned no grand campaign but simply
at each turn tried to advance justice in
whatever small way the opportunity of
the moment allowed him
solidarity meant much more to the pope
than just the union that lec valensa
came to head for john paul solidarity
was an idea that he had first defined in
that 1953 book catholic social ethics
the portions of that book that you will
find reprinted in man of the century may
amaze you they spell out a recipe
for a catholic social welfare state
radically different not only from
communism but also from the utopian
capitalism promoted by many american
politicians many of them catholics
john paul as i show by quoting his
speeches has continued to espouse these
same social welfare ideas ever since
specifically into the 1990s specifically
endorsing after communism fell
the grain of truth he called it in
marxism
that grain of truth that criticizes
capitalism
he opposes the notion of profit as a
primary value
an ocean which has filled the void left
by the fall of utopian socialism
and this is the tragedy of carol voitiwa
in his eighth and perhaps last full
decade of life his ideas were subverted
within a year of solidarity's victory in
large part by the very western
politicians who love to portray
themselves as the pope's allies
this turn of events is and and the
pope's feelings about them are described
in the last part of man of the century
entitled judgments
i hope i've piqued your interest there
are forms here available for ordering
man of the century but as noted you can
also pick it up in
any good bookstore
often with a discount and
it's cheaper yet on the internet at
either barnesandnoble.com or amazon.com
i will be happy to answer any questions
and i thank you very much for listening
thank you you haven't been shy about uh
stating your opinions so i think we'll
open it right up
for questions they're not opinions and
that's important to me i hope there are
conclusions from evidence that anyone
would conclude the same thing from okay
i'm going to start with this gentleman
here uh yale richmond
we can use the microphone if you
identify yourself here and other people
who know they have questions if you can
put your hands up i can begin to get a
list i'm yale richmond i'm a retired
foreign service officer who's had a long
love affair with poland dating back to
1958 when i was cultural officer in the
american embassy warsaw i take issue
with you that there was no support from
the u.s government for the solidarity
trade union
now that may have been the official
position but it was not the actual
position because during the
during the 1980s
i was the program officer for poland in
the national endowment for democracy
and and i know
that we channeled at least one million
dollars absolutely that that's that's
different and i i make that point very
precisely
in 1984 that changed i was talking about
the years at issue 1981 the 19 the
beginning of 1984 which were the
critical years for solidarity the ned
absolutely uh
expanded by a third the amount of money
that the international solidarity was
taking in but that again did not come
from the reagan administration it came
through the national endowment of
democracy
through the afl-cio which had been held
this
the national security council
which i was in constant liaison and i
have to assume that the cia i have no
direct evidence of this i have to assume
that the cia was doing the same thing
during those years and earlier but can
anyone cite an anyone in poland and i
talked to all the underground leaders of
solidarity that i could track down and
their stories are accounted for in here
and every one of them explains how his
underground press was launched how the
radio transmitters were built and
absolutely denies that any of it came
from the cia this during the ned period
it began in mid 1984 you're absolutely
right and i hope if i led to a
misunderstanding of that i apologize for
it i was talking about the period prior
to that from the crisis of solidarity in
1981.
yale do you have anything
okay
at the great basilica at yasnagori in
chesterhoba you walk through there and
you see
the entire walls are festooned with
everybody's military medals for hundreds
of years
uh handmade rosaries uh you know this is
the polish people's site
and i wonder if you would comment on
this deep religious background far
greater than anything we see in america
and how that influenced
in both directions the relationship
between vortia and the polish people in
making a
solidarity come out of their religious
background
nothing i could say
no words shakespeare could find
could adequately convey to you how
important the black madonna at
chestnujova
was to this entire enterprise a symbol
of polish nationalism it's what the pope
referred to in his inaugural address
that began to stir up this mass movement
it's what at every instance um he called
to mind uh when needing to revive the
polish people the meeting i described to
you early
earlier where he burst in on the meeting
between uh
general yarazelski's emissaries and
cardinal cassaroli was at chestahova
it's a monumentally important shrine
you're you're absolutely right uh and if
i'd known there were people here who
would recognize it i i would have thrown
it in
pressure
i was wondering did you interest
i was not allowed to
interview the pope i hope
that will change still i'm told he's
positively inclined toward this book
which i know he has and
has familiarized himself with through
his press secretary is one of the three
or four closest people around him who
they decided would cooperate with me and
who gave me many many hours
and certainly if they had wanted to
prevent this enterprise they could have
blocked cardinals from talking to me and
they did not at each time a cardinal
asked for a reference from dr navarro
walls the vatican press secretary
the pope's personal press secretary as
well as the vaticans
dr navarro vols
helped me and
that's the way they decided to handle it
and
they're very cautious about any
possibility that the pope could be
misquoted misinterpreted or anything
could be directly attributed to him that
might not be the way he wanted it
i was allowed to to write down questions
by the way that and dr navarro vols
would submit them to the pope and i
would get back original answers to uh
unfortunately a minority of those
questions not all that i wanted but some
of them
i'm curious the extent to which uh you
were able to supplement your interviews
in poland with interviews
um here perhaps in russia and you
mentioned
the situation czechoslovakia
to see how much
so congruence there is between um what
you were hearing from interlocutors in
poland and
stories elsewhere well i have
quoted
again i couldn't go
everywhere and see everyone and my
attempts i really had hoped to go to the
soviet union on this
book i had been
previously um to and to talk to
gorbachev among others gorbachev
declined to see me
and
i made do with the work of the number of
scholars who were quoted in here and
with some of the wilson centers those
those thick books of
translated documents that come quarterly
and were very valuable
um i did talk to
czechoslovakians and then people in
hungary and romania by phone and met
churchmen from there in
in rome a churchmen in czechoslovakia
were very important in this enterprise
because there was this underground
church in czechoslovakia but many of
those people
came to rome under the pope and after
the fall of communism okay right here
the main interpreter of
well the main
yes interpreter of
john paul's doctor
you made interpreter
machine gimbal
who has written extensively on the pope
he's certainly not the main interpreter
of john paul's doctrine
well other people would lay claim to
that title but
no i haven't talked
yes
that side with the navy i have personal
interest you were saying that you
couldn't find any evidence on the famous
assassination
from bulgaria and the soviet union can
you tell us what your best understanding
of that event is
well
it's not that i couldn't find any
evidence it's that the italian
government
prosecutor's office which was the
supposed source of the whole story from
claire sterling and uh
all of the others um it was their
evidence that supposedly
established this fact
they could not find any evidence it all
fell apart in the trial of the
bulgarians um
and i went over all of the details of
this evidence
the most i mean we could spend a half
hour on this but the most striking
single piece of evidence to me of claire
sterling's long article in the new york
times and which the times
adopted as its own um
was and and in reader's digest and on
television was this truck that
supposedly was parked at the bulgarian
embassy as a getaway vehicle uh for
oddssa and one or more of the bulgarian
plotters right after the assassination
attempt three times in that
new york times article in separate
paragraphs she said it was the only time
such a truck
had been parked there with special
customs approval to seal it so it would
go through the border
uninspected and that it left shortly
after the assassination attempt
in fact the italian prosecutor's office
with the testimony of the italian
customs officials under oath
showed that that truck was there every
two weeks that the same
to the same as it was uh similar trucks
went to every embassy
that
the uh the same procedures were followed
always that the truck was parked not
inside the embassy compound but was so
big it couldn't get through the gate of
the bulkarian embassy and so was loaded
and unloaded out on the street
and most of all
left many hours before and apparently
the day before the assassination attempt
ever took place it could not possibly
have been the escape vehicle that all of
these accounts say it was now there are
a dozen other pieces of evidence and
unless there's i mean if there's a dozen
people in here who want to sit around
who are
experts who have devoted years to the
study of the uh bulgarian connection
case i'd be happy to discuss these
pieces of evidence with you but similar
to that one they all fall apart
there's nothing left now it's hard to
prove a negative if somebody can find
some new soviet person or document that
will start building a case again
i guess we all ought to listen to any
new evidence but every piece of evidence
everyone that was behind the so-called
bulgarian connection case
vanished and the italian prosecutor
who's still supposed to be trying to
bring a case against the remaining
bulgarians
acknowledges that there is not one piece
of evidence
so the alternative explanation is this
alone not gunmen remember the
that
had
before
solidarity right after the pope was
elected uh oddssa had uh
published in a turkish newspaper that he
was going to kill the pope he was angry
that the pope
had come to uh um or was scheduled to
come to istanbul uh in an attempt to
bring the the churches together the
eastern and western churches
and uh
odds threatened then to kill him that
was two years before the assassination
attempt took place and it was before
solidarity was founded okay
yes my name is paul hensey i don't know
if that means yes it does you're one of
the people who wrote those books uh i
began long before claire sterling and i
continued long after claire sterling and
i was not dependent in any way on what
italians found
i happen to know
the turkish situation very well and most
of my evidence was gathered in turkey
i gather you didn't set foot in turkey
in connection well i've set foot in
turkey but not on this matter uh
to me if the italian prosecutor who was
the original source of the entire uh
according to claire sterling's articles
nothing better than claire sterling's
articles to go on you really have very
little your your your approach is is
really naively journalistic well could
you cite any evidence
the italian prosecutors they went to
bulgaria
prosecutors if you've if you've uh
seriously read the book i've read your
other material and i don't know why you
why you continue to talk about the new
york times the paper for which i'm not
sure if you were writing for it then the
wall street journal
the wall street journal was one of the
uh one of the principal
uh journalistic
uh
organizations that worked on this
subject on the editorial page i was on
the news site well the wall street
journal worked on it on the great page
worked on it but never declared that
this was a fact as the new york times
did and as you did i'm an enormous uh
admirer of the pope uh and i
have been involved in all of these
things probably much longer than you
have i was of radio for europe from its
beginning and i and i noticed you've
never mentioned radio free europe which
is why i mentioned it constantly it is
the one organization it was an
invaluable organization i re i credit it
over and over again i wonder if you
interviewed people uh who were
i went to radio
i can't imagine these people
we're all enormous admirers the pope i
think your your basic thesis stressing
uh the importance of the pope is is very
good but i think in when you come to the
80s you veer off into in into grotesque
interpretations which seem to be to be
motivated by uh
tendentious attitudes toward president
reagan the u.s government and a variety
of other people and this just doesn't
hold up i i agree entirely with gail
richmond the the i was in the national
security council as as all of these
developments occurred uh there was
absolutely no discouragement on the part
of the u.s government uh to undertake uh
efforts to support uh the pope or just
undertakes efforts to support solidarity
well let's get away from attitudes
interpretations and words
who was a primary source who i talked to
for hours with his uh uh
deputy uh
juwanna polarska uh was in charge of the
polish underground's attempt to raise
money overseas he told me and i recount
in here specifically of the many many
efforts that he attempted to make to get
money out of the united states
government established some liaison with
the government
hoyetsky of the underground press um uh
severan bloomstein a very important
figure in paris in raising the money
that helped support the underground
press um uh gee uh bogdan borisevich the
the man who really helped with end and
uh um
uh romanovsky's veneer romanovsky and
and this uh recharged uh klitschko in uh
california who built those radio
transmitters all of them talk about how
they were the ones who put together the
underground press and the transmitters
let's try to offer me any specific what
underground transmitter what underground
press uh came out of washington what
piece of evidence is left of your book
about the bulgarian connection that
somehow the italian prosecutor has has
uh in his strenuous efforts going going
even to to behind the iron cross
obviously it doesn't pay to talk to you
you've convinced yourself you're an
advocate of your own
okay what i'm going to do we're just
about out of time i'm going to let paul
make a statement if he wishes and we'll
take one final question or paul i have
nothing more to say
as i say i find the i i would have a
great deal to say if if i felt this were
really worthwhile but i don't feel it's
worthwhile i think that's my case an
extraordinarily tendentious
interpretation
read the facts
john
in layman's terms would you characterize
the post-political abuse of being that
of a social democrat
or the pope's film
this is touchy because the pope very
much resents all of these
categorizations and the idea that he is
a
middle
way between communism and capitalism he
sees himself as having proclaimed
something very positive which he stated
in catholic social ethics stated again
over and over
most principally
in uh in race socialism his encyclical
in 1987
in a series of uh speeches he gave in
mexico in 1990 in a series of speeches
he gave in the baltic countries in 1993
it's a positive program
i compared it in the book to
his being basically a roosevelt democrat
but
he considers it unfair to label him with
any normal political
label and wants to state the political
things he uh
believes in on his own and
that's why an awful lot a man of the
century
is uh in indent in his own words where
i've isolated his ideas on particular
subjects away from religious talk
and tried to make them clear
well it we are uh now out of time so i
need to bring the session to a close i'd
like to thank
jonathan for coming down to new york
mentioned that man of the century is
available um
in bookstores i think
um
it's sometimes more important to clarify
disagreement than it is to
find agreement and this is one of those
sessions where clearly we have
established
areas which
will be explored and debated in the
months ahead and i think that that's a
positive development and i hope that as
we move forward
that
some of the issues that have been put on
the table today will will receive more
attention and i think if nothing else
that is important examine the evidence
not arguments evidence thank you very
much
[Applause]
even scholars
one point
for more programming on authors ideas
and the business of books watch about
books you'll see lectures and speeches
by authors interviews with booksellers
and